[Music]
Bona part's restaurant is in D
straights new owner Sur has sunk
everything into it it's frustrating the
hell out of me at the moment cuz going
nowhere the customers are nowhere to be
seen how many booked non Garden nothing
at all no chances of Walkin perhaps SL
the kitchen's down to two staff and the
money has nearly run out I'm going in to
identify the
problems I'll find out if the Market's
there how much you pay for that Fair a
lot what
you if a team are pulling together you
takeing [__] penalty and if the head
chef is clued up enough you're taking
the picture you know
that I've got just one week to turn this
restaurant into a viable business the
honeymoon's over got to start making
profit
[Music]
now next to its Posh neighbors illey and
Skipton sits silson
a little workingclass town yet to make
its mark on the conry map of Britain
lots of um fish bars cafes quite a
quaint little place little small
Yorkshire
Town bonap part's wine bar and basement
restaurant on the high stream was taken
over by its current owner just over a
year ago in her time sua sold everything
from Donkey rides to caety wall
installation but the restaurant business
is totally new to her and so far the
locals aren't biting good afternoon good
afternoon Sue is yes hi please to meet
you likewise so how's it going bit
quieter today how many did you having
for lunch about two two ready that's it
and last night last night I think we did
only two again that's all two customers
the whole night two customers the whole
night yeah unfortunately it's just died
to death absolute death the Stark truth
is that 2/3 of restaurants don't survive
pass their first birthday and as things
stand Sue's in danger of adding to those
statistics as a last resort she's placed
all her trust in a 21-year-old head chef
together they believe that fine dining
will guarantee Bona Parts a brighter
future it's like being an artist you
know what I mean you just start from
from nothing and create something so I
think that's why I love being a chef
from a humble start 5 years ago washing
dishes Tim has had a meteoric rise
obviously I would like a couple of
restaurants maybe three be leads and
London New York you know wherever just
big cities you know so that that's my
main ambition and obviously to make a
lot of money Tim's ultimate dream is to
become a TV chef you put pal on through
this but for now he's embracing his
first opportunity to run his own
kitchen and how did you find Tim uh he
found me um he knew I'd been struggling
with chefs and uh lack of them and he's
very ambitious he must be [__] good
if he's a head chef at 21 know either
that or he's a [__] good
bullshitter it's pleasure to meet you
sir likewise and just pleasur Le so
you're the head chef yeah and you're the
well you're obviously going to be the
second Chef there's only two of you busy
lunch no no absolutely not no one I
didn't think so when you're standing
there twiddling your thumbs no su's food
Takens are a dismal £200 a week she
should be clearing at least 10 times
that but she's not even covering Tim's
wages let alone food cost and
overheads chefs can't get excited unless
there's customers to cook for I'll never
know how good they are unless there's
any customers in the [__]
restaurant uh Tim Ham's booked non
Garden nothing at all no chances of
Walkin perhaps slim I want to see you on
a little bit of pressure tonight right
it's 5 to 6 I want you to get out on the
street go knock on a few doors and
invite some locals to dinner Get your
coats on and [__] off for some customers
if the customers won't come in off their
own free will these two young chefs are
going to have to go and drag them in
excuse me we'd like to invite you for
fine dining requires the ultimate in
presentation surroundings and service
just have one you just but most of all
it requires faultless
food we just need the people coming in
now Sor it's like a big cake you've got
all the
ingredients and you can mix it you're
just got to find right consistency make
it rise you go okay I'll see you there
cheers the reputation of this place
can't be that great even with free food
from the fine dining menu on offer
they've only managed to pull in 11
guests for any head chef this would be a
walk in the park first order two pigeon
mles one Venice and one brw okay where
did the tickets go um well I just put
them there cuz we never really get
enough to worry about it oh [__] me
that's nice who's doing what who's doing
the fish I'll do the fish what would you
like do tonight uh I'll do benen what
I'm trying to say is how the [__] do you
organize your kitchen oh Le take care of
the hot starters I'll do the cold
starters you do the fish I'll do the
meat we jump on theing then Le will
stand here and I'll do this one and just
when when I'm not doing anything then
I'll just jump on and help him you know
how to
organize within reason within reason
okay here we go where did you put red
ble with the first orders in now I can
really see what's going on in the
kitchen
what was that I just trashed a loaded
balls better send the bread first don't
you
yeah never mind fine dining they can't
even get the bread right it's [__]
Frozen get it back in the
oven are the pigeons ready yes we're
about to put them in the bin because the
bread's Frozen pigeons are cooped and
the [__] Bread's not even out
there and if you toss that [__]
cabbage once more I'm going to ram up
your ass okay cage you everything you
turn around it yeah let's go come on
even when the kitchen's busy you should
be looking to get the starters out
within 10 minutes of receiving the order
thank you very much these poor souls
have waited half an hour for the pigeon
breast with mushroom
ravioli and that's not the only problem
Tim you made a r yes it's burnt you not
taste that there no smell it then you
honestly can't taste that
burn but now now you point it out yeah
go [__] in the bin this is really
worrying a head chef who can't even
taste his own Foods burnt he's not going
to win any prizes for his control of a
kitchen either and there's only two of
them in here one I need an egg okay can
you hear can you hear hold on hold on
come here they're buzzing they're
buzzing in the background that's the veg
of the microwave that should have gone
with the main cause 4 minutes
ago come on Tim get the [__] things
out for some an our's weight is just too
much desperate to keep her staff cost
down se's got a hands full running the
bar upstairs and seems blissfully
unaware of the far that's taken place in
the
basement kitchen was a
disaster a disaster beyond belief the
blind leading the blind and the left arm
not knowing what the right arm's doing
and you want 50 60 seats filled down
there and they've got 11 customers in
for dinner and up to eyeballs in [__]
I mean real
[__] everything's going in these Cutters
for some bizarre reason they think that
Rings is the sort of alternate F dining
experience but super I don't understand
what the hell's going on there I don't
know all I know is I'm not making money
so I don't know what they're at or where
they're coming from but it's Sue's
business and she should be in
charge look at the [__] mess huh I've
ever seen such hard work for 11 guests
no doesn't make you feel good does it no
not
really I've got just one week to make a
constructive impact on boner Parts but
by day two I'm clutching at straws to
find any positives to build
on Sue lacks focus and has clearly lost
control the kitchen is such a tip it's a
health hazard and worst of all the head
chef and his mate just aren up to
scratch I must be missing something
um
gentlemen Tim sing a dish scallops
scallops can't wait to sit nearly every
successful ran has a dish that is
renowned for I'm hoping that by cooking
his Tim will produce something truly
memorable something truly worthy of a
place on a fine dining
menu that's your signature dish which is
um scallops with uh deep fried p and
black pudding sauce H Anders mhm
certainly looks
okay what do you
think he got to be
sick he's only gone and given me a
rancid scol
up someone get him a drink drink
[__] how can you eat that if you knew
they're off what didn't you say no I
didn't I didn't know they were off
they're [__]
minging you don't taste that I do now
yeah took a while till an
hour I know what it means I feel sick
myself
now it's um it's Grim it's [__] grim
and it's out of
order I didn't realize you were [__]
off so I suppose it's my fault
really that could kill
someone that's the bottom
[Applause]
line in the two days I've spent at
bonapart I've witnessed total
incompetence in the kitchen total lack
of direction for the management and last
but not least they've tried their best
to kill me with a rotten
scolar what the [__] you playing
at sorry sh it's not about being [__]
sorry you shouldn't be in a [__]
kitchen if you don't know what's right
and what's wrong in that sense this is
basic [__] cooking you know
that I need to check if there's any more
surprises lurking in Tim's kitchen
there's a look in
here when are they
from uh Saturday Saturday would you use
them today no no so what the [__] they
doing in the
fridge it looks like rabbit [__] that
one that's just some lentils oh this
one's stuck to the [__] glass yeah it
lookss like sheep's turd that's been
infested with ants we've got [__] fur
on [__] potatoes when's that from
tell you what we doing with them throw
them in bin throw them in bin but you
keep them in the frider two days before
you throw them in
bin but you see what I'm trying to get
at does it make [__] sense yes or no
so all this [__] fridge is jam-packed
with [__] and we're standing here saying
put bin going put a bin well get them in
the [__]
bin this whole kitchen is disgustingly
filthy in allowing things to Fester
Tim's putting Sue's business at risk
[__] hell can we get that one cleaned
out as well yeah yes just one bad thing
can contaminate a whole fridge Tim may
as well just Chuck money out the window
a health inspector would have a field
day do you know what I'm [__] Gob
smacked you know that I got a good
[__] mind to get hold of [__] Sue
and just tell her to [__] close the
place for you know that cuz this is the
[__] pits you should be ashamed
Rock bossom I've never seen anything
like this in my entire [__] life you
know that cuz this is a [__]
embarrassment to
catering let alone [__] ringed out
fine
dining let's
move not a best start it could have been
where it to be honest [__] like sorry
right
sorry the picture is becoming painfully
clear Tim's completely unqualified to do
this job he's blagged his way in and
Sue's been naive enough to take him
on when you do put so much like hard
work into creating stuff and then you
don't you don't use it you then you get
bored what I've done like football is
playing with no football in it they just
run around what's point will sit on
their asses after a while W they that's
how it
is all this ingredients in there and no
customers to send it to and yet none of
them have been communicating with each
other you know that's got to go tomorrow
can we turn that into a fish pie can we
do something with it but no the blind
leading the blind and every bloody
ingredient in that fridge um is is is
money your
money Sue has no idea what's going on in
her own
kitchen key to any successful restaurant
is regular communication between
management and the head
chef I really need to get these two
talking just had a word of me said it's
not very impressive
we need to keep the place clean and
everything tidy otherwise I can be sued
in which case I'm out of business and
you're out of a job realize that yeah I
know and I've Tak this had to take it on
board as
well well just you should have to stick
her R in she was going to say I told you
so but that's what she were doing yeah
fair enough she had a little dig so what
[__] you know what I
mean relations between Tim and Sue
clearly aren't healthy
Lee yeah goggles gloves before we do any
[__] cooking in here now I want the
place absolutely spotless goggles on
please that's it show me you handsome
bastard it's not just the kitchen that's
at fault here any clu Up Restaurant
knows it's damn stupid to attempt fine
dining in a basement let learn one
that's beneath a busy
bar Sue Panic is obvious when you see
the weird mix of fine dining menus and
Scrappy handwritten boards advertising
TV name cabes bonap part's image has
clearly confused potential customers she
was trying really to think to do too
many things to be all things to all
people so she was trying to have you
know live music and have an internet
cafe and uh also the impression that you
got when you came in was she'd be
shuffling around in her leggings and her
slippers
I don't think she's going to attract the
people that she wants to attract it's
not as nice as the one that s across the
[Music]
road the newly opened competition just
200 yards away has been fully booked
since it opened so the punds are
definitely out
there it's time to find a clear identity
for bonapart and make a clean start
Valentine's night is Just 4 days
away it's one of the most important
nights of the resturant calendar and it
can make or break a new venture
if we're going to reinvent Bona part's
image we've got to do it now but we Sue
accept the DraStic change of Direction
I'm about to
propose it's
clearly not going to work as a f iring
experience does Tim know how much
pressure you're under financially I say
flippantly you know I'll end up going
bankrupt if you're not careful but he
doesn't realize how true that is yeah
mean how close ey in real terms in real
terms um
probably
I've got probably 3 months maximum Jesus
you know I'm I'm willing to take
constructive criticism it's not working
is it otherwise we'd have more people in
the basics are wrong I mean the the
basics are so so wrong and it's you know
it's embarrassing it's got to go back to
comfort rustic easygoing food it's got
to become more of a beast stro cuz the
place oo is that kind of
style I know Sue's convinced but if him
to flush out Tim's pretentions to fine
dining once and for all I need to
provide him with evidence that he can't
fail to take on board gentlemen Tim all
right this is a seed scallops with a
baby black pudding with a nice Holland
days km pepper sauce and a bit of deep
fried pararan it looks like potato but
I'm not sure first time you had a
scallop and this is a beef and Ale pie I
have a bit of b i I'm a past face
me yeah beautiful the sculps and the
black pudding and the Palmer ham how
much do you pay for that well I want to
pay a lot what do you well I don't know
scops a de anyway so 850
850 one and what would you pay for the
pie oh about £8 about £8 £7.95 oh what
fire off 895 well
done which one would you prefer well I
like the pie personally well I I like
the meat definitely meat L thank you
gentlemen thank you one nil you [__]
all a lot Tim needs to learn a few basic
Resturant rules if you don't know your
Market you'll never get bums on seats I
would probably go with this one two
[__] nil next please have we got two
seconds here's another one have you got
two seconds restaurant without customers
will go
bust you don't like scolars 3 n you
excuse me put another way Tim needs to
start producing food the people of silon
won't be able to resist that is gorgeous
sh that for that you wouldn't pay 8.95
for that in in the major cities yeah I'd
expect to that is very very reasonable
and delicious are you listening I am
listening Beast through that's where
we're going yeah fine
[Laughter]
dining who's going in for
it it's not bad news you know that it's
[__] good news news great news yeah
and it's it's it's clear the is on the
wall she's come to the end of the till
up there that's pretty obvious that you
she's she's had enough huh yeah yeah is
that clear yeah it's clear yeah and and
you know you're [__] cocky with her
you know that yeah yeah and she pays
your [__] salary are you mad how much
have you put in here nothing yeah not a
[__] penny not a single penny but
you've taken from it haven't you y so
now it's time to give back absolutely
definitely and not cooking for egos get
rid of it Back to Basics you know that
what I want you two to to do just to
confirm that we do know the basics both
at the same time cook me a [__]
omelette show me something that I can
eat and be happy
with an omelette is probably one of the
first things you learn to cook at catron
College when was the last time you
cooked omelet I hav't cooked one
before I've never cooked an onet before
oh don't be stupid I
haven't
look inside what does that tell
you um slightly overcooked slightly it
tastes like [__] rubber I'm both
overcooked that was [__] by any
standard you're a head
chef you're taking the pcture you know
that
you are taking the piss you know that
yes
GED gives you nothing back and the whole
idea of telling him off is to sort of
help train him and educate him but
clearly not used to being told what to
do right make me another omelette [__]
it that's
go any shef worthy Soul should be a able
to Source good quality ingredients at a
good
price the locals already think boner
Parts is too expensive they want value
for money for Sue to start making any
sort of profit Tim Needs To Be Clever
about what he
buys two baking sandwiches please and
two cups of
tea he needs to wake up to the real
world he's clearly a need of some
inspiration for his new beastro style
menu thanks D thank you that's your one
that one don't spill on those new
trainers will you n try not to the
Chinese tongues tonight we got a table
of four in want you okay to buy starter
main course and pudding 20 quid 5 quid
per head I want to see how clever you
are with that money
[Music]
right morning morning morning good
morning love I'm making french onion
soup right we're making some um french
onion soup today so uh we're looking for
some like sort of rustic like the all we
do is we get in this
[Music]
window can can have a look at that
clearly Tim's never bought anything from
a market before in his
life discount for the trade any discount
for the trade discount for
the with that it's always worth baring
before you know that so when you're on
the telephone in the morning you're
checking with your suppliers and you
want to know how much the fish is you
can always bargain with them I bet you
don't treat serious money this way do
you I will do from now on [__] right
you will
Tim's menus are packed with expensive
fish and meat cuts he needs to open his
eyes to the tasty less expensive options
on offer yeah what's that next to the
pig's
head what is that there
and that's o tail oxtail you ever used
oxtail before no what would you do with
the Brazen steak I don't know really
maybe barbecue quite nice on barbecue
you know and when you get them going
brazing State means [__] brazing so
it's telling you what to do with it so
what would you do with it where it like
a stew can't put that on the [__]
barbecue just looking for some chicken
breast some nice chicken breast there
you go look he's showing you nice check
it have a
look how much is it how much is chicken
per breast yes how is 12 there it's a
lot less than I get it from my butcher
is it your butcher is more expensive
yeah Jesus four of them please any uh
discount for trade discount for trade
how much was it 12
forward that's my boy do for me cheers
can I have a bill please uh a receipt
with the at with
vat you'd come again yeah absolutely the
more they see you the more banter you
have with them the more bargain you get
with them and the cheaper it becomes you
know that
yeah yeah oh definitely then the restant
starts to make a bit of [__] money
yeah get the picture yeah I get it
thanks [__] for
that how much we spend just over 12 quid
12 quid fantastic for four portions
brilliant okay Fred onion suit it costs
75 to make a portion okay how much did
it go on the menu
for you times it by four and that should
cover everything $ 295 for a bowl of
soup and we've made money on that and
one thing we're not going to do with the
ingredients we bought this morning is
waste anything we waste
nothing with the Valentine's at traag Gs
are just 2 days away I'm under no
Illusions as to what we're up against
[__] Lim dick in the kitchen you know
that go give some [__] energy [__]
21 for God's sake you should be getting
[__] 12 hardons a day not one a
[__] month let's go Le's got a bit of
nouse whis but I've got to hold Tim's
hand every step of the way now are you
sure you want to be a chef yes you are
yeah in right into the center this is
our one chance to see if Tim can cope
with his new beastro style food bring
the knife out put it back in and bring
it to the edge there yeah yep gently
gently gently gently
make love to it don't [__]
it outside leaves yeah what do we do
with them you throw them away yeah we
usually throw them
away but before we let him loose on the
pain customers I've asked him to cook
for four special people in the privacy
of their own home what I haven't told
him is for his own family you like stir
it into it or no you leave it dangling
on top so it gets perfect of course you
let it [__] stir inside we've got
soup chicken larang pie yeah
let's go and surprise Mom and Dad shall
we let's go around to their house and
you cook their tea okay you sauce for
the [__] f
um I don't I don't really I'm asking you
yeah I I don't I don't think so good the
center is is the sauce the garlic sauce
in the center okay
now Hallelujah we don't need a je we
don't need any je
woo hello MCH how are you surprise I
hate to use Tim's folks as guinea pigs
but with the three course meal already
prepared all Tim needs to do is reheat
the soup and cook the
kyes should we get cck where's
Grandad this should be a walkover even
for
him I'm going to leave it all to you
busy
bre he was always in the kitchen as a
boy wanting to wel B cuz he loves
talking about it doesn't he yes yeah but
then he decided whilst he was at school
that that's what he wanted to do and he
got himself a job in a kitchen and it
just went on from there told me that he
was going to be a chef and he was going
to the good food show to meet Gary rhods
and off he went fantastic look what's
happened
yeah burn it burn it don't burn it here
we
go
Sor keep you waiting that's quite all
right he's ready I'll
get let's not forget Tim is a head
chef [__] hell oops burn my P have
you I might have done just Burn
yeah last thing I said don't forget your
croutons he's managed to [__] where his
Grand's
house
ladies
first this is some french onion soup
thank you minus the croutons what are we
going to do with this num
Fu a look at that superb torched on the
outside and pink in the middle as for
the lemon rang pie you would get a
better reception if you threw it at
the Tim family wouldn't dream of
criticizing him but the paying customers
and Valentine's night won't be as
forgiving it
we got 44 books for Saturday night mhm
and you fued it for four what chance
have we got for
44 I'm now starting to [__]
myself it's my fourth day at Bona Parts
Tim's first attempt at cooking a
simplified beastro meal may have
impressed his Grand granny but he and I
both know The Awful Truth it was a
spectacular
flop you you paid as a head chef aren't
you yeah do you think you should be a
head
chef not really thank [__] for
that don't start crying I'm not well you
look you're about to [__]
bubble okay so you're delighted with
that bookings for tomorrow night at
Valentine's Cabaret are piling in with
nearly booked to capacity I'm trying my
hardest to stay positive that's fine Mr
L I'm sure you'll enjoy it but with just
a day to go it'll take more than high
energy drinks for these two to pull it
off when someone's been told off the
first thing you do in a kitchen is come
back at 100 m hour
and this guy disintegrates every time
you're telling something he just
disappears into Oblivion and loses all
sense of concentration that little short
span that he has why don't we swap the
rolls around tomorrow why don't you
become the Sue chef and Lee become comes
the head Che for tomorrow
night no answer whatever you want to do
guys [__]
kitchen you're supposed to say bollocks
no I'm the [__] Chef my name is Tim
gr it's me on the menu
no yes or no yes oh
Jesus maybe it's me I should try the
softly softly approach we got big night
Saturday night it's full and think the
first time since you've both been here
that the place is full okay and whilst
I'm here you're not shafting me as well
at the same time you know that we going
to work together over the next 15 20
minutes I want you both to think of
something really simple menu wise three
starters three main courses and three
puddings what do you think Le
soup Yeah by passing some of the
decision- making back to Tim I'm hoping
to build up his confidence and install
some pride in his food it's hard to
write a simple menu when you've had your
head up your ass for so long doing
trying to make fancy silly food that's
the kind of stuff we're going for in it
so what have they come up with main C is
liver and onions mashed potato macaroni
cheese fish and chips mush peas L shot
pot L shot pot that sounds nice and you
come with the ideas together yeah we
we'll just flip through some books and
thought what what's simple and um you
know basically thought what did we used
to have at school what did we like at
school and and not forgetting where are
we where
in
[Music]
Yorkshire we're getting there we getting
there in devising this new menu I'm
aiming to take most of the pressure off
Tim and Lee during service 90% of the
food can be prepared and perfected a day
in advance let's go see if you can show
show me you can handle two pens at once
as long as it's made Well it can't fail
to be a hit with the
customers there should be 15 things
going on there all the same time time
coordination understanding medium pink
is it Well Done onions roasted bang in
short Bona parts and new beer menu is
designed to be idiot proof yeah that
definitely identify them as vegetarians
yeah let's go come
on so far Tim's attitude towards Sue has
been that of a stroppy teenager rather
than a respectful and supportive
employee going to go on um a tomato soup
a rustic tomato soup yeah some little uh
cheese f probably a first he actually
come to I've had to run down and Chase
all the time then I need this and then
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah it'll come later
I said I need it now basically you just
put them through some but uh crush them
up today seems a lot better don't know
what he's been doing to him down there
but he certainly
improving in the week I've been here
I've hardly seen Tim or Lee sample or
season anything they've
made no wonder their tasteless food is
failing to woo the customers everything
we do in this kitchen has to be tasted I
don't care if it's a [__] bread roll
a lemon merang pie or chicken KF you
have got to start tasting
things from now on bland is off the menu
you just wait and to teach these two a
lesson they'll never forget I'm
resorting to dirty tactics you know what
a medium steak tastes like
yes Does that taste like a sirloin
T-bone steak or is it a rump
steak sirine
sirlo it tastes like sirine [__] you
here we go now for the open
up okay tell me whether it's medium or
is that well done medium and well done
well done none of you got that right yes
yes pork pork and [__] lamb [__]
now you don't you don't realize
until someone blindfold you and feed you
that your pet's
so
nonactive could have been worse could
have been chicken then we would have
look like [__]
idiots oh [__] Tim's had a week of
nonstop grief from me wa wa put the ball
down this boy has really tested my
patience all right how do we know
they're ready
now you can lift them upside down yeah
there you and I really don't know if any
of it sunk in go I'd love to just get it
and put it
on
[__] but with more than 40 guests
expected in just over 2 hours time he'll
soon be tested to his absolute
limits I SLI oh no don't tell me it was
the mud it was
mud can't even take a [__] penalty
I'll say this for Tim he's no quitter
and I don't want to see him fail but now
he's got to prove he's master of his own
kitchen we're not leaving this as a draw
you know that hey in cooking nobody
draws ever one thing's for sure tonight
he'll either sink or swim
W
yes woo no
upstairs possibly okay good news good
news another two so we're up to 50 48
now so's never had so many bookings
she's having to move furniture out right
to fit more tables
in you happy with that chicken K we
roasted Vine Tomatoes T-bone steak with
homemade chips because there's so many
involved for dinner I wouldn't stall
them upstairs for too long you're really
going to dump Us in it big time CR
cocktail three bean salad with mustard
dressing what do you think
oo very true yes I like I hardly dare
say it but this place has got a real
Buzz about it there's one thing missing
what do you like on all your
menus oh his name's not ah
Bingo and where should we put that on
the back or I don't want my name on it
we work as a team and it's a giant
effort and be you know that's it that's
the most sensible thing you said to me
all [__] we you know
that thank you
every decent restaurant in the country
is full on Valentine's
night the competition down the road is
packed to the rafters and for once so is
boner
Parts in a small town like sson business
thrives on Word of Mouth and if
tonight's a disaster it could break Sue
I have got a fear that he will not be
able to cope with the numbers especially
when he's saying that 11's busy I don't
think
so so we'll see what it's made
of Tim has got to get this right two
fruit stairs two soup two chicken okay
hey 6:00 first order's in okay hello
Chef yes well give it to Scott Scott
first order in hey are we going to let
the kitchen border call out the tickets
or you going to call them out come on on
order two soup two chicken one creme
bruy one
tree let's go soup's made get on to boil
Scotty put some water in it
please something's burning what's that
burning it's just on the a it's on the
grill thing there not the crout on there
no it's not the crw on don't burn the
croutons I'm not burning soup's on yeah
yeah pan on for the chicken not yet I
think we should put the pan on first
yeah start the chicken and as they're
eating the soup the chicken's cooking
yeah okay are you all right yeah yeah
first order in it's upstairs you're okay
well you depends not on for the chicken
yeah don't burn the croutons
okay all right how long for that
soup 45 45
seconds oh [__] off you thany what the
[__] are you doing other
way young
man what are you
doing slow down talk to him Lee can you
send the two soup please wait
look at the
croutons charcoal again oh God this the
first [__]
order what's the matter nothing no well
you're cooking like an absolute [__] you
know that yeah just take your
time big deep breath and talk to Lee a
little bit you're just on your own
spinning around round and around and
just creating a [__] bedum yeah calm
down get yourself organized yeah and
control yourself now [__] come back
to me a little bit come back to me a bit
yes
[__] come on Timmy Fresh Start or
we're going to go down like a sack of
[__] fast better Le look at him look hey
nice and bright give us a
smile it's well done isn't it yeah yeah
come on get
in team worked 2 minutes some
eventually got you can have two orals
out of there mate
please on order three PR cocktail one
soup one sirine medium One Tone medium
one sirine medium so don't R the STS got
a lot of stuff to get on
here communicate
good got as soon as you get some smaller
am you need
them how long fo veg one and
[Music]
half
sending them yet y
yeah on order one prawns one beans one k
one sirine well done one lemon one
Bru right Scotty to can have two oralls
out M please good that's it told the
Gade now now you talk to the team which
is fantastic keep it going
yes you stop
talking we're going to go we're going to
go down yeah yeah hey it's not quite
right but at Le is moving Yeah Yeah
medium with salad that's a medium on it
so without salad and that's a rare yeah
we out salad
[__] give it together yeah yeah yeah
let's not get nervy food was was
excellent yeah very enjoyable it's what
we expected to have really and it was
really tasty and really enjoyable it's
nice how many more to come please Sue uh
there's another four four I overbooked
actually the local competition tonight
has got 46 book if we do this last four
we've beaten them yeah what do yeah does
that not just lift the morale up a
little
bit medum medium medium medium and
ladies and
gentlemen Showtime Cabaret I'd like to
introduce Tom Sawyer who after cotel get
some holidays on you call service please
uh Scotty take it
away one t bone steak medium and one
chicken Kia please and that's all going
to table 12 tell these two first please
put a
together watch the color look when it's
brown is cook when it's black it's
[Music]
[__] what a past Tre please pies B
first B
first
[Music]
Beau two s l medium not finished yet but
yeah well
done Tim's gr and Grandad are
celebrating their 44th wedding
anniversary at last Tim can repay them
for the rubbish he served up a couple of
nights ago with a delicious well-cooked
[Music]
meal it was lovely that sck it was
beautiful M did it yeah hey you hear
what that back
[Music]
memories you really surprised me tonight
and I'm really seriously over the moon
that you didn't [__] it I'm serious H
yeah cuz the first 15 minutes of 6:00
you acted like the biggest [__] in
Britain you know that all over the shop
and you pulled it back together and that
wasn't me that was you and the feedback
from them out there has been brilliant
what does that tell you what does that
what does that put in there I had a
service like that for a long time and
these stupid [__] illusions of
grandeur and all this stupid fine dining
crap that you're trying to do it's gone
do you understand yeah exactly where you
are now yeah yeah totally understand do
you understand what you're capable of
doing within this restaurant yes stop
trying to take it Beyond something is
never going to be you'll [__] the
restaurant and you'll [__] yourself Big
Time mhm so never forget tonight it's up
to you now not to allow it to go back to
where it was I've been too soft you have
to be yeah exactly I'm glad you're
saying it because exactly what I going
to say next and I've also
um allowed him to have his head too I
also think you've been confused to what
you want because you haven't been
focused on One Direction for the
restaurant because you've been you know
jumping all over the and that's part of
a panic and that's wrong and now now
tonight clearly evident exactly what you
need to do from this day onwards and if
he changes anything I'll pickle his
nuts when I arrived at bonap Parts a
month ago it literally had no
customers head chef Tim gry was a
liability I didn't realize you were
[__] off he couldn't even cook an
omelette you're taking the pcture you
know
that in one grueling week we transformed
bonapart from a failing fine dining
restaurant into a buzzing be
stroke with Tim sending out quality food
to nearly 50 contented customers on
Valentine's
[Music]
night but since I left Sue's given Tim
two written warnings over his
attitude now I'm back unannounced to
find out what is going
on turn that [__] thing off my God
what's going on chilling chilling it's
Friday night it's 7:30 how many's books
four four and you got the music blaring
away yeah I'm just where's Lee he's
upstairs on bar he's in the bar what the
[__] is that in there muscles you're not
serving them are you yeah what the fridg
is
like my God Almy what is that [__] in
there is mold and fur dear oh dear so
you haven't changed have you oh [__]
h a whole week druming into their thick
skulls and it comes to this holy
[__] this is a living [__]
nightmare nobody in this place is taking
control and in this state a health
inspector would close them down without
a second
thought so I got to show you this
because it's part of your responsibility
and this is your GFF there you go
should not be in you didn't see this no
I didn't actually In fairness to Tim it
was it was doing okay it seemed to be
okay for the first 3 days and then it
went and then this is not ride this is
this is [__] miles away this is a
nightmare you know that cuz it's more
loss on top of more loss and more loss
and more mold that's what worries me
because you need to touch that you need
to rub your finger on that you need to
go to a chip you need to season
something you put your finger in the
tomato soup and and then they're all
[__] you've just contaminated the
whole place and that's what really
worries me this kitchen is not fit to
cook a [__] thing in right
now and there's your
problem I think I better just
close and put due to
refurbishment and you should bur out
gracery you know
that just been giving him another chance
and another chance that's that's I can't
tolerate that it's just going to end up
it's professional suicide isn't
it he con me simple as that I don't
honestly think he did it deliberately I
don't think he's a a nasty piece of work
I just think he lives in a Wy world I
begin to think that he's just convinces
himself to be
honest to go
from Valentine's Day evening to this
is it's not even fun there's just
something wrong with it
the is Valentine's Day are good man I
don't think I've gone home to bed or
whatever feeling in a better happier
state of mind and tonight I don't think
I could go to bed in a worse one it's
beyond recognition really Ain it how
[__] stupid
that that someone can be you know what I
mean it's a dog
one and who is that someone to no that
would be me pretty
much
yeah well at least the bar's busy that
is one Saving Grace but really thank God
she closed that kitchen down because it
was [__] disgusting I mean really
appallingly
bad shockingly bad you just let me get
on with it it be a d better let you get
on with it this floor be KN in sh1t
before you rang me up all aggressive I
were get in on with you fine I would
respect you giving it all the like
gentlemanly bloody stuff I could do and
then you went and shot it down [__] p
no don't tell it on me if a floor is
filthy want to turn yoube it doesn't
matter anymore Flor was filthy does it
matter yes I think we I think we've
established that look yeah [__] the
[__] Flor that's
[Music]
[Applause]
worse
people dream of owning a restaurant in a
quaint town like this setting beautiful
countryside cooking fresh local produce
serving loyal locals as well as the
tourists a r to die for
surely but the glass house is in deep
trouble [__]
Partridge [__] all right do our hotel
yeah we not losing it oh the [__]
no that's D the kitchen's in chaos and
the customers are Mighty unimpressed it
was rare the other half was just about
and it was so and it was really
disappointing it's losing money like
there's no tomorrow and the owner's
about to crack up I'd rather not be here
i' burn the bloody place down you know
better not put that on camera he's at
his width then so he's called me in to
turn it around I've got just one week to
do it and that's a tall order garlic
popcorn I will will save Neil's
restaurant I won't tolerate excuses last
night you had bad breath no hiding place
and no
[__] you're talking out your ass
I'll go anywhere you're talking out your
[Applause]
[Music]
ass not allowed sometimes do Neil
Farrell has always dreamed of owning a
restaurant but in 3 years since he
bought the Glass House his dream has
turned into a nightmare
he's deep in debt so many people are
after him for money that he's turned his
mobile phone off he could go mad and he
may even go
bust when it's your own place and it's
your own money and you're you're the one
that's you know walking the tight Road
it's it's it's very it's very different
and that's my problem that we haven't we
haven't worked out which road we're
taking no no at least he's had the sense
to call me in for help but if Neil's
going to pull this one out of the fire
he's got to take some tough decisions I
I can't do that for him but of course I
can encourage him first off the kitchen
to see if the chefs know what they're
doing the head Chef's 37 like me he
trained at clares before my time he's on
25 Grand a year so he'd better be good
about the same amount as you did the
other day until he says I can call him G
and he's Mr Ramsey har are Ram he he
thinks that there might be some
confusion with Harry
Ramon's first I need to watch him
and see how he runs his kitchen
everyone's nervous that they're going to
call him Mr
Ramon morning Mr Ramsey extremely
pleased to meet you likewise first name
Richard Richard where do you think it's
going wrong it's a very difficult
question we've beit bit of heads against
many a time what we're doing wrong
should we turn it turn it into a
pizzeria is that what people want you
just got to the stage now where I just
feel it ain't working and I'm
questioning my ability
to control his team and Inspire them the
head Chef's Got to Believe In
himself otherwise forget
it two cloths check Cesar salad battered
salmon hello no communication not a
Dicky bird no one even answers the head
chef no no fck no no we Chef no nothing
I have to ask for it oh you have to ask
for it n times 10 Craig you're not lost
of words are you no not at all big hard
man like you
we how's it
going time to test Richard's cooking I
thought what would be a nice thing to do
um just for today for to go upstairs and
have a quick bite to eat for yourself to
just in your hands you're going to
you're going to you're going to cook for
me you choose your favorites your
specialities I want three duck cake
putting in he's not having those he's
having four fresh ones yeah up of which
he's going to eat
two Richard's proud of his duck cakes
with chili jam exotic no pretentious
crap they Scotch
eggs Cam's
BS and someone's been very lazy in the
kitchen cuz they got a bloody
bone
so I'll say that one for
later another of his favorite combos bra
lamsh with pnip crisps it's very clumsy
clumsy cooking and lazy elements the oil
on these
stink but it has been changed about 3 or
weeks the whole meal would set you back
nearly 30 quid way too
much okay
guys the food was disappointing sadly I
did choke obviously saled L but that was
um stuck at the back of my throat but
however you know I'm glad it was me not
a pain customer a owner's best
investment will always be in the chef
and if you haven't got that sort of
major asset downstairs in the kitchen
then forget it the guy's got to be a
motivator it's got to be a leader it's
got to make you money he got to bring
customers back and clearly from what
I've seen so far Neil hasn't got that in
Richard that's pretty
obvious next job to see how Richard runs
his Brigade on a busy night good head
chfs get the best out their team no
matter
what he in was a waiter but got bored
serving food so now he's trying to cook
it
instead Ian's girlfriend CLA only works
here part time as her main job is
running a book shop I suspect she's only
here cuz she's going out with here
thought wild animals that have nibbled
at it but
nothing Randall the kitchen Porter
thinks we're related because we're both
from Scotland
BS you T
this Craig Craig's in years here to at
caon College he looks pretty clueless to
me but let's hope he proves me
wrong a good team will always turn out
good food whatever the
pressure it's one of the busiest nights
of the Year Saturday at half term so
it's a perfect
test what is that there are 106
customers book if they're happy they'll
spend an average of 30 qu each plus wine
and The Glass House will take over four
around but their biggest problem is
coping with lots of orders [__] D
[__] upstairs are up their ass is a
second [__] call away from
non-existent
table Neil did tell me when the
pressure's intense the kitchen collapses
into chaos and you know what it's true
someone answer me someone have look in
the he ends up giving meals away things
soon go from bad to very ugly no it's
not [__] all right do our H tell yeah
what happened for the
fat was horrible it hasn't been
trimmed fat F yeah that's exactly what
it is yeah take it to Richard Jay get on
the phone now find out where this fish
was
going the whole thing's gone pearshaped
everyone's running around like headless
chickens um eye off the ball and um just
a massive breakdown in communication
[__] Partridge you I need a bigger
piece of SE bass do give side order
that's gone up needs to come back and
that needs to be cooked some more you
want this [__] Partridge cooking more
for [__]
sake I need another Partridge
CL Rand have you just been reading the
right check it's really Grim my
apologies Chef 36 have had their status
we've had the order in for 40 minutes
yes say that's not good enough where's
that big check where that's a big check
you break your [__] balls and you're
really do for
it yeah and you know what [__] why
Restaurant Rescue I'll tell you how you
can rescue me restaurant buy it off
me [__] buy it off me mate then
you'll do me the biggest [__]
favor you
could I think someone's about to piss
his pants I think he's just gone
there
[Music]
I've been at the last House restaurant
in ide for just a day from what I've
seen so far it's going to be bloody hard
to turn this place around in a week a
month possibly but now it's inquest time
there's no question where to start that
cocky Chef please 11 chips it was going
well huh 10 9 I went outside um have a
quick chat with customers and all of a
sudden I started seeing this food coming
back huh where do you think it broke
down F me not using the guys properly
but the guys just [__] let go as
normal and things were coming down just
went [__] chaotic say every [__]
Saturday we've ever done was exactly the
same maybe I just shouldn't give a [__]
maybe I should just say [__] you give us
your money thanks very much then it
wouldn't bother me and I could go home
and it wouldn't matter if I've got a
[__] restaurant cuz there's loads of
them out there and the owners are
driving around in bloody Porsches I'm
driving a shitty asro van and I'm
[__] close to tears do you know what
I think Neil would rather throw himself
in Lake windir then actually turn around
and be the bad guy with his
staff it's not all kitchen fault but um
you the kitchen's the engine room yeah H
Richard yeah if we're not firing all
pistons and we're not you know on the
ball Craig yeah come here you one yeah
come in the chef's answering you a
question what was his question question
was what happened at 20 P night where
did we go we were [__] mot you look
like a sack of
shite
well at least have the bollocks to
apologize to him he's standing there
boiling his [__] eyes
out yeah take your [__] hat
off we've hit rock
bottom don't get
upset huh
hey I'm telling you I don't want you to
get upset the team will need a real
boost if we're going to get back on
track it was all going so [__] well
but there's still some problems to
tackle it's my second day in the Lake
District trying to save the Glass House
restaurant and I tell you what it's an
uphill
struggle next battle hygiene this place
is about as clean as a puppy's litter
tray the secret film was taken last week
they knew I'd send someone to check
around but they didn't know it was Mark
Sergeant my head check for
clares and they didn't know he had a
camera hidden in his
hat plastic containers they instantly
tell me the food is not as f as it
should be even the head Chef's not sure
rather you than me
mate this kitchen is filthy straight
from the dirty floor into the pesto it's
supposed to be a kitchen not a building
site Gordon's going to have their
bollocks with
morning let's go Jesus look at the [__]
over there that cleaned every night was
cardinal rule of cooking your kitchen
must be clean and by clean I mean
spotless the normal clean down which is
what every Saturday night after service
we do throughout the week but you must
have one big clean the week now just
don't have the T Randall don't [__]
it's not [__] at the end of the
night the last thing I want to do is
look up end of the night make time
clean kitchen clean
food lazy kitchen Porter
p45
Randall but it's not just up to the
kitchen Porter everyone should be
responsible but they're
not youve got to trust the Brigade that
you'll pay and secondly um you know
bring them on evolve them make them
talented keeping hold of them motivating
them um evolving them increasing their
responsibilities working on them don't
me think how much time we spend to go in
the kitchen all day long yeah looks like
family is it's exactly that what we
spend it's the first family we spend
more time together in the kitchen than
we do at home with our bloody
families nothing more I can do till they
finish time for Neil I do wish you'd
turn on his mobile phone grow some
bollocks and act like a bloody boss
there are too many customers to cope
with on Saturday nights but the rest of
the week the place is deserted that's
partly because no one can find it when I
walk past for the first time coming down
here from the right hand side I had no
idea where the restaurant was yeah and
here we should have a nice prominent
sign Glass House restaurant with a menu
board beautifully lit and whether you
want to put some little bloody neon
lights or nice fancy lights around it is
an attraction right and and and that Lit
see that sign there the glass house and
with a new logo and the new printing
just something that you know um speaks
value right yeah um cuz it looks it
looks too comicy doesn't even say we're
a restaurant does it it doesn't say
you're a restaurant exactly I want to
see a bloody telephone number on there
salad salad um duck cakes now for the
menu a well-written menu should TI
customers inside at best this one is
confusing at worst it's just bizarre I
don't want to
popcorn gar popcorn where the [__] did
that come
from so something the vegetarians always
say that they've got no there's no
crunch or no body in any of the dishes
they got no pet what you worry about
vegetarian yes for God's sake
vegetarianism is on the decline um lunch
menu two starters two main courses and
two puddings yeah I'm just wondering how
many people are going to come in for a
two course lunch yeah um we're going to
look at the menus to the two course and
if that's hearty rustic countryfied food
then trust me because I know you don't
want to let go of the sandwich and I
totally understand I want to let go I
just don't want to let go of the revenue
I serve sandwiches I got no problem
serving a lobster roll suckling pig
sandwich yeah I've got no problem um a
beautiful um beef sandwich I've got no
problem serving sandwiches
whatsoever okay guys Craig yeah open
macel sandwich work down good man like
the seasons with a clean kitchen we can
improve the food and I can find out
exactly how the team
Works th
flowers gently now cuz they're very very
very fine and then Craig yeah taste it
there's your spoon Craig looks scared
stiff making a mistake you have to
change that if he wants to be a chef Sal
hav put it in yet good up
saland if it's not a hot pan what
happens the fish in the pan it won't
cook yeah not only that smart but it'll
boil so we got no color on it two more
round the outside in the's got some bad
habits but he's only been cooking for 3
months I think he may make it one day
know you know the whole thing's Chang in
color and it gets halfway what does that
mean turn it over turn it over exactly
but we're just going to finish it on the
bottom okay good good question you're a
very very good cook yeah I don't know
anyone ever told you that
before this restaurant is going to be
better than the BLT yeah up and over
good how do you sandwich like a cat
that's got the cream
in no different from a BLT that better
than a BLT not as good as a big m not
as bra you know
that in a well-run kitchen everyone
makes a contribution but Richard hasn't
even asked his team what they think the
problems are Craig what's your um week
point in the kitchen this is when I get
a lot of orders on I don't have them in
front of me so I I get the get shouted
out once and then I have to probably
check the ticket again put it together
in your own mind then just jot it down
Saturday night's quite hard when all the
checks are coming on mhm and I do kind
of lose where I'm at how many steaks
I've got on order and how many mhm but
when it goes quiet it's kind of like
it's difficult to motivate yourself it's
that's what Richard said yeah yeah Rand
is that your third one sorry second one
Jesus Neil's finally agreed to a new
lunch menu simple fresh food for a
tenner including the new mackerel
sandwich just had to taste each others
this is good I'm glad you enjoyed it at
last some happy customers we got a
restaurant full of happy people
fantastic chive small amount Ian treat
it with a bit of love and care place it
in there gently yeah and you don't throw
it
[Music]
in my God the kitchen suddenly sounds of
is running well one salmon one sausage
yeah wait check random sweep the floor
please done already you've done it
already well it's still dead I want to
sweep flower everywhere yeah and I
didn't see you do it anyway what time
was that what time was
that when you're doing bracing just here
it's 1 let's go nice wi there you go can
you let me know when that 3 minutes cles
front within 30 seconds every section of
the kitchen's talking to one another
good everyone in the team's responding
but Richard is not working with them you
want him to help you
put
all this is what I want to get
established quiet lunch not really that
busy I just want to see us working
together even more now I know there's
nothing for you to do right now but
there's yeah I know it's painful but get
him doing something for you please thank
you and you hey
oh I ask you can I do anything for you
Richard yeah what do you need doing okay
s where are they Mash r on your what can
I do bring the baget together even
Richard said to me the guy that's got no
man management skills he's been watching
you and the way you are with the guys
and you're bringing out the best in them
you're bringing out the hunger that's
what you pay him 25 Grand a year for I'm
not I'm not being funny or pissing
around with 25 Grand a year is a lot of
money but I've been stupid with them
I've been cradling them my head was too
far up my bloody ass to realize what the
hell was going on
Neil needs to get his head out his ass
and focus on his job keeping customers
happy and making sure they spend their
money roasted pepper and tomato GPO he
needs his customers to bypass the cheap
early supper menu that runs till 7:30
and eat alak cart and that's how he'll
pay off his debts and rebuild his
reputation let me just tell you
something 15 portions of apple cake 15
portions of fondant and 15 portions of
bloody gratt and doofen Wars five nights
a week it's £125,000 a year turnover hey
on three items out of nearly 20 on a
menu
yeah the last table that just arrived
said they're early 15 minutes early so I
want to make sure that Neil doesn't give
them the early supper menu because we're
going to find out whether or not they're
here for a bargain or not and I want to
sell the alart not the Cheapo menu cuz
they look like they've got a bit of
money now you got two menus on today
you've got the alart menu we've also got
the early supper menu
um so you got lots to choose
from table that table just arriv we said
they're really early 20 minutes early
they're booked at 7:30 so therefore
don't give them the cheat
menu the table of four yeah just sat
down right what did you give them I gave
them both yeah damn will he never learn
Neil must work the tables not worry
about the kitchen if you're only focused
You' do a fine job do you know what you
are a phenomenal salesman you got the
most amazing wine seller and you can
take an order you can take an order and
you can cane it on the wine and the
better the food the more money they're
going to spend on
wine after 3 days things are looking up
the guys upstairs are starting to get
the basics but my big worry is the
kitchen Richard just isn't earning his
25 Grand I'm really sorry for saying it
but the guy CHS no form of inspiration
so if he's not inspired you know these
young guys are going to dwindle away
that's your little kingdom yeah control
it it's the biggest problem in the glass
house but Neil just won't face the facts
I'm going to have to show him how well
the kitchen can run without his head
chef don't take this the wrong way but I
want you to take the night off tonight
and I want you to take the night off now
I love both you to have dinner
together don't have to e here to
we
yes
doy yes you are when was the last time
you guys had dinner together truthfully
without any [__] I went to about two
half years ago two and a half years ago
yeah hello two and a half years ago and
when was the last time you sat and it
here no never done it can we do it yeah
can do it thank you there's only one
condition that this takes place the
kitchen downstairs don't know about it
and I need a bit of support from you
guys as well yeah cuz it' be too
exciting I've sent Richard home the may
not be up to this and if it goes wrong I
may look a right tosser yeah we had a
absolute Nightmare Night last night I
left you together for 2 hours and it was
the biggest [__] hole in Britain yeah
I'm going to rectify that you're on the
hot plate you're going to be running the
kitchen okay and then if it's going
really well I want you to run the
kitchen for half an hour and God forbid
if it is going that well yeah scratch
your head scratch your ballocks I'm not
interested I want you to run the kitchen
for half an hour yeah right maybe from 1
1:30 2:00 in the morning I don't know
yet let's just really work for each
other yeah let's not lose the plot and
let's show him your Chef that you
guys are more talented than he believes
you are
okay tell you what why don't you thank
you why don't you host the
meeting yeah play two seconds yeah let's
go right me I'm shutting up okay you
host the meeting you call the shots
right soon
got soup pumpkin pumpkin soup by way
it's on your section fish pie with
peas got 12 and we've got one more
downstairs need be 30 shling Pig how
long comes out in the oven about 8
minutes okay that's fine apple almond
cake y pretty good okay really well done
yeah little pan of that not little kiss
though lovely going to be okay and we're
going to improve to them especially
riches but we can do it without them
yeah don't worry don't worry about
it okay CL yeah no worries yes ready
yeah table 37 has arrived and it's gone
7:30 so they'll definitely get the alart
menu want Sal
yes cheers
mate hi CH Cocker I can only pray that
Neil taste the difference in the food
then over a nice glass of wine can give
Richard what four into the center of the
cutter think about what you're doing
don't rush it Craig what are you
doing this tub labeling this tub how
about looking at the food and show a
little bit of Interest what you're doing
okay pee Le tart little bit of sparus
and just BL that
round this is [__]
amazing try that to
no
TR if you don't eat that soon mate I am
told you had a sexual experience
downstairs in the kitchen for the last 3
days well done well
done don't send it Randall don't send
it watch
theot thank you well done thank you good
good good good I'm good
Rand away table 34 please when he's gone
are you going to be able to instill what
he's instilling Ian's now in charge of
the kitchen
everybody how l order Ian please one
lamb one moose Pig one
do you got to sustain it now forever
know do you know what I mean I am
[__]
myself to produce this food I am really
really [__]
scared but
I'll die
try been a lot better than last night so
far yeah also yeah um is that not
because rich is not
here I'm not going to say what you not
going to say we won't have a job if
we let me ask you you've got a pair of
bollocks has it gone well without
Richard it's gone
smooth from the money Point headchef
Richard has been given the night off so
I can show the Russian owner Neil how
strong the kitchen is without him I
think the team have done a bloody good
job but we Neil agree table 37 uh
thought the food was absolutely
fantastic they' like to uh come down and
meet you and the rest of the team are
they local or are Lo in the
oven that's table
37 I mean that well done you responsible
for that
food Neil looks delighted but has he had
the BS to read Richard the right act yes
thank you very much no seriously guys it
really was nice it was absolutely
beautiful we did what tonight we all did
it intense good made us all do we all
just kep sing sections we all work
together as a team and we all we all
read club together it was great you let
me down tonight no we've done you proud
I think I thought it very well down
there went
smoothly
tonight for the first time in such a
long time I went and had a
meal that I can't complain about at
all can't it [__] sex on a plate guys
remember you're my boys my girls at the
end of the end of the time mine but I
need to know in the next two days what
you're going to do with your shop Jesus
Christ I don't know [__] I [__]
don't know you want to go and sit in a
book shop doing [__] all for the rest of
your life that's your
decision I said it was your decision
when you want you know the book Shop's
good for my degree I can get my degree
there got me by the shot and Cur
that the team performed bloody well
tonight without
Richard and Neil should look really
close at that because that is a bad
investment
I'm more than halfway through my week at
the D house the good news is the kitchen
team are doing really well last night
they cooked without their head chef
Richard and did a great
job but Richard's still struggling and
Neil the owner isn't tough enough to get
rid of him do you think he takes
advantage of you because you're such a
nice guy to work
with sometimes yeah but then I think
everyone takes advantage of me he gets
paid that amount of money each and every
month and it's a bloody good salary but
there doesn't seem to be any onus on you
know evolving let's get better he's got
to make money this is your livelihood
this is this I this is your your lease
your livelihood your family your money
and if this
goes they've all bugged off and got a
new job know that and you'll sat here in
the [__] so you're taking a bit out for
service yeah myself I'd never put
Richard back in the kitchen without him
it's a happier place serving better food
but it's Neil's
decision you know realize how much
talent's in here yeah the guys I've got
and what I was saying to them last night
at the end of the day we are a family
and we've got to work it out uh you're
the leader you're you're the big eye the
big inspiration I want them to come on
so this slides back down they'll slide
back down no slide back
down my next challenge to relaunch the
menu by the end of the week so the Glass
House can start to win back his
customers maybe Richard will finally
show me he can run the kitchen as far as
I'm concerned is his last chance for the
team it's another opportunity to prove
themselves good that's the most
important thing about being a talented
cook you know that having that inner
strength to turn around and say no stop
that's not good enough and what did we
talking about yesterday mistak staying
where in the kitchen every time and the
minute you break that cardinal rule and
you start sending those mistakes because
you think the chef won't see it yeah I'm
going to can your ass you know that yeah
and um you know like you said they want
first step of the relaunch is down the
menu want give a little bit Twist on
there and when I went through the the
menus last night late last night 85 to
90 dishes yeah how on Earth we get to
control that you know over you know it's
it's a lot of lot of gear on there and
no I've not actually sat down and
counted it uhhuh if the menu is reduced
and we've got six starters six main
courses and five six puddings we're
going to sell more of them yeah so the
more we sell of them the cheaper it
comes to make especially when we doing
the lamb shanks yeah I personally don't
want to see Frozen but lovely in
Brackets next to chips if you don't put
that then the bug is turn around and go
it's a lovely meal but I can't believe
your chips are frozen you're the only
restaurant I've ever ever come across
that writes Frozen but lovely hot
fat vegetables in as well as reducing
the menu we have to make sure the food's
top quality that's the team job color
them enough so roast them main course
local lamb I've no doubt CLA can improve
on the fatty lamb shank I had when I
first Ed here
that's what we're looking for there
exactly what we're looking for but I
want it all the way around not just on
the top hurry up then we're going to
make some better better pudding the
bread and butter pudding leaves to serve
here was pure starch my version should
be perfect for the new menu I put Craig
in charge of the recipe the God is up to
it what do we flavor with this
time Vanilla baes ba so as it Cooks the
whole thing not becoming dry yeah okay
very we good and my spies told me last
week that we didn't you can wash this
lettuce for Caesar salad I don't want to
hands in there yet and a dish they could
become famous for a classic Caesar salad
that's one for you salad so it's
live look at the Contour of the plates
going around so I'm putting the top part
of the salad around the outside of the
plate we're going to lightly
glaze the warm egg in the
center
parmesan crispy bacon and then nice
crispy croutons around the
outside there you go the new glass house
Cesar salad fingers off
look here wipe
it yeah a brand new menu and a fresh
start if all goes well tonight we'll see
The Glass House
[Music]
reborn 70 local people have been invited
to try the new food everything
everywhere has got to be just right and
I mean right I mean
perfect don't take this the wrong way
yeah and I mean don't take this the
wrong way last night you had bad breath
okay yeah and when we're standing there
talking to customers and you're trying
to sell them something yeah it doesn't
smell good even Richard seems to realize
the importance of tonight's launch
listen I'm fired up it's [__] going
to work yeah yeah let's scream it let's
[__] shout Chef when I call a check
out yeah wait for the end of the check
yes chef yes yeah come on we
Chef looking at reducing the menu
Richard and having um slash the prices
this is not an expensive dish put
together is it not no not at all fresh
I've designed the menu especially for
Richard everything's cooked in advance
so there's no chance of a mistake and
the hadock cost absolutely nothing this
morning what was it 70 p a pound yeah
yeah and it smells
lovely sex on a
spoon um who have we got in uh that we
know tonight a table of all the people
locally that got the b&bs B breakfast
there's quite a few in the media we got
the one of the head guys from the
tourism mhm they want to contact you so
make yourself available I'm going to
recharge me mobile which I uh turned off
many months
ago Hallelujah Neil's behaving like a
proprietor with balls proud of his
restaurant right yeah I'm fine he's even
booked the guest in shifts so there's
less pressure on the kitchen progress at
last we' just got everybody in by the
8:00 so we got 25 minutes this is easy
way hello hello we have never
met and in 2 minutes time our hour
silence starts
CLA yes if the kitchen's quiet everyone
can concentrate then it should be
impossible to confuse
orders be made up way yes
[Music]
oh no come on Randall Randall come here
we're supposed to be working together on
this aren't you rich is calling out
orders and you're tipping cuty upside
down can at least wait till he's
finished first no sure so once he's
finished talking to his Brigade yes we
can give him an answer sure well this
Lamb's definitely better off the
bone your
favorite really good very very smooth so
hopefully touch with rest of the night
it'll be even
better SWAT tables you still have three
Cesar salad and one pressed ham rich is
back in charge of the kitchen there's
only food to reheat and salad's the
[Music]
dress the dressing's missing that's all
apart from that it looks
lovely two pieces pett
please Ian's distroy but it is Richard's
job to check everything before it leaves
the kitchen let's start moving on your
toes now yes yeah good lads good lads
come on let's not go down guys he's
starting left he making a lot of noise
at the front but he's not leading the
team quick quick
quick nail tables 4921 next orders are
piling up again we got we got to speed
this up we're looking bad not tonight
please not tonight we not losing it oh
for [__]
sake come on Rand
quicker five fish Pies Two 3 four five
six six total two at the front
play 15 that's Dam don't really know
what the hell's going on in there but
you know let me just say for the last 3
or 4 minutes um being there it looks
shocking where's check on CL 49 it's in
the top no don't go 49 yeah you got the
number they really have managed to [__]
it up properly
again and they don't have to cook
anything except dress the salad and talk
to each other they can't even do that so
uh this is a [__] embarrassment wait
one second listen yeah that's fine take
one Cesar salad out
please yes Salad out change the table
number to 51
where 51 next I'm not taking any
prisoners
anymore I'm seriously not people don't
pull the away they're out of here
because I'm not [__]
about I won table 12 um what's that
there for Rich Neil may say he won't
take prisoners but surely he can see
Richard can't cut it but instead of
plucking up the courage to sack his Chef
he moans about my Caesar
salad don't get e all St big
too big in comparison to what you were
serving yeah I know what we were serving
but the source with that is absolutely
beautiful the dressing it's very rich
absolute pants total bollocks that is a
proper Caesar salad done what I haven't
done is crushed the lettuce and the [__]
I saw last week with cooked jumping on
the salad and squashing now let me
finish squashing the salad up the side
of the bowl and you're telling me that's
too big that is fresh salad goofy washed
and I haven't even put my hands in it to
dress it I've let it dress it self in
the bow so what you're telling me is
absolute bollocks and I'm ready for a
[__] argument right now you're
talking your ass an argument if you want
an argument you're talking out your ass
can we go outside I'll go anywhere
you're talking out your restaurant you
stop you're talking out your ass there's
no point talking to he's going to use
that langage restaurant oh
really amazing he's got big enough
bollocks to stand up to me but he can't
tell his own Chef who's paid 25 Grand a
year that is time he took his
p45 and it could never go Qui we
survived the evening but only just I
shouldn't care but I do like these guys
and I want the place to be a
success F time here I am so distraught
with Richard tonight he couldn't
organize it couldn't control it and you
know what he had nothing to bloody
cook
it's my last day at the glass house he
it's red tree time yeah how far is it
from
here about 2 minutes the most important
thing now is to tell the real workers
that' done a great job I didn't think I
was actually capable of doing the sweets
until he actually came but now I think
that I'm just starting to get the Ang of
it m and we will keep the standards up
because you've really done done a lot
for the kitchen and you've done a lot
for me personally as well you've done it
for yourself all I've done is drawn it
out of you that's all got it in here
yeah that's it that's you've done it
like I felt like today when I had my
little time to myself I just couldn't
couldn't help but just stand there and
just go bloody hell this is me
m had any sleep you haven't had any
sleep since last night no my God why
haven't you been sleeping just adren
just the rush of the job so the rush of
the job oh yeah inspiration I gu
you honestly haven't slept no Daddy Hell
Rand this is not an sas course you know
that Randall got to get some sleeping
boy so fired up he hasn't slept God
maybe we are related after all wood wood
wood wood wood wood wood wood wood wood
through you have a natural touch with
food you know that you walk around the
kitchen like a
ballerina just the way you position
yourself you're agile you're on your
toes and I still can't believe you've
been cooking for 3
mons yeah right touch yourself just get
it okay yeah little bit I'm really going
to miss CLA cuz your strength over the
last seven days has been
inspirational I think I'm going to sell
my shop and I'm going to get it back
into the kitchen as soon as possible I
think that's a good
idea B ramsy thinks I'm a really good
Chef oh my
God Neil had a word were you guys have a
word every night after service what did
he say last night he gave me the options
three options and took the third one uh
what were the options well one one to
leave two to take a pay cut and uh drop
down the ladder and three to stay work
my ass off develop the guys carry on
with what we've been doing over the last
few days and and go for it are you
confident that you can become the new
glass house
Chef yeah
truthfully how long will you give him
pully Sala a month a
month yeah just promise me one thing
yeah you make the [__] decision and
you stick to it I want more than
anything in my heart for Richard to
prove me wrong and I hope he
does never let your mistakes leave your
kitchen Randall I want you to hang that
up with a bit of Pride and passion and I
want that to place that disgusting dingy
horrible yellow smelly clock downstairs
come in
hey's that
[Music]
Chef 3 months have passed since I've
spent a week at the Glass House
Restaurant trying to rescue it from
disaster menu looks nice nice and
small now I'm back to see what if
anything has changed hello Neil hello Mr
Ramsey how are you how are you good to
see you yeah I'm fine thanks you look a
lot more relaxed you you look a little I
I you look happier I'm a different
person to the one that was here it's a
different Neil to the first person you
saw when you came in and I'm complete
I'm more confident you know I mean you
came in and you highlighted things that
I kind of knew that they were there but
they were buried in the back of my head
you know you brought them all to the
Forefront and and and I'm glad you did
that but God what a week though I mean
we went through the roller coaster and a
low things were really Grim when I first
came here sadly I did and by Grim I mean
catastropic that was um stuck at the
back of my throat but however rich is
calling out orders and you're tipping
Cutlery upside down yeah I'm going to
cane your ass you know
that not tonight please not tonight the
kitchen team came into their own when I
gave head chef Richard the night off
good good good good and bloody good let
me ask you you've got a pair of BS has
it gone well without Richard it's going
smooth I'll die trying you're talking
out your ass go I'll go anywhere you're
talking in the midd restaurant you hated
my Caesar salad I didn't hate your
Caesar salad it was just too bloody big
I still stand by that um the big
question yeah who's the chef Richard
Richard is still here yes he's
downstairs he's downstairs I'm going get
and he's nervous so be nice to him yeah
right be nice morning guys good morning
Gordon how are you Richard how you yeah
sound one thing I have noticed as soon
as I walked in the kitchen is how these
plastic containers start creeping back
out everywhere look all them along there
yeah they're back the new dishes that
you've involved um and and put on the
menu why they we're doing a tagio
pomegranate Rosato mhm uh which that
sounds intriguing so we got a crunchy
pomegranate seeds yeah mixed in risotto
yeah sounds [__]
revolting oh [__] me welcome back this
is a new dish that we put on tell me
about it that's a puff pastry yeah we've
got
some onion over there we got put G
cheese on top of that nice to see
Craig's
cooking and we sold about seven when we
put it first on what have you been doing
new and exciting to tell me uh got a
tofe fruit crumble on now tofy fruit
crumble
yeah with crum fresh no you can't that
sounds really nice in the mid
I mean absolutely
beautiful I thought Ian had real talent
I'd give him a job in one of my kitchens
any day and his
girlfriend and where's my sweetheart CLA
where where is
she uh she had problem selling the shop
couldn't get out of it and uh she comes
in at weekends gives us a LIF at
weekends keeps her hand in it's a shame
she's a big
loss and my fellow Scott Randall he's
gone too
sad this is risoto with tagio
cheese flat leaf parsley and
pomegranate be nice to win him
over Neil's hung in there but it can't
have been easy it's gone closer to the
wire than I'd realized how close we to
closing the door very close worst thing
for me was like not being a to pay the
guy
at one stage I didn't I didn't think I'd
be able to pay them you know and I think
these guys they put the effort in they
put the Graft in they've done everything
there and they've always been behind you
um and it's like suddenly you can't put
any money in the pocket and it's been a
constant struggle but it's like now I'm
I can actually say to myself well I'm
going to start reaping the rewards and I
will do you know and I'm a lot more
positive about it in fact January has
been fantastic weekends of been busy you
know there is a difference in the food
you know presentation it just looks
slick it tastes you know tasty well
thank
you still a booger still not convinced
about my pomegranate Roto that's going
to think about that one on the train on
the way back cuz that yeah that beats my
[__] head in that one um it's been a
pleasure today has been of interest um
keep it
up there's lots to
celebrate turnover up 20% and Rising the
restant is building a good reputation
and going from strength to strength you
never know Neil's nervous breakdown
might never happen when you come back
just buck on someone else's name s yeah
that's it now every bloody name that
books will be going guy sounding funny
on the phone I'm telling you it's
Gordon God I really hope they succeeds
and I really hope they do well but any
chef that comes up with a risotto
finished with bloody pomegranate needs a
kick up the ass
[Music]
again pomegranates in a [__] rotto
they must be off their [__]
rocker the walnut tree in is in
trouble stop now okay you take over and
see if we can pull ourselves together a
little bit and get ourselves out of the
[__] because in 15 minutes this place is
going to be the biggest [__] hole in
Wales the head chefs quit and the
kitchen's a joke cockroaches live on the
floor you're not a [__] cockroach
even with that hairstyle you're still
not cockroach the customers have fled
and the owner so broke he's had to sell
his house so he's asked me to help him
out but I've only got one week to find
out what's happened and turn things
around you shut it okay back in your
corner and listen to what's going on do
you know I said do it I'll show the
owner where he's going wrong welcome
back come back where the [__] have you
been and do everything I can to help him
and if he doesn't cut his prices and
listen well quite frankly he's on his
own [__]
it
hundreds of restaurants open in Britain
every year but over 2/3 close in the
first 12 months the walnut tree in abeni
has been one of Britain's most famous
restaurants for nearly 40 years set in
beautiful Welsh Countryside is the proud
holder of a covered michion
star it ow his outstanding reputation to
this man Franco toio he was one of the
first celebrity chefs 3 years ago
Franchesco matioli another Italian BN
the walnut
tree I know him well he's managed some
of London's best restaurants I need an
answer guys so he should know what he's
doing I've come to find out how in just
3 years he's managed to mess it all up
morning sir how are you how are you all
right you're losing weight again no I'm
not losing weight what's the smallest
numbers you've done in 3 years is it is
it for lunch for dinner once it was a
Thursday night and um Michin star
Michelin star and it didn't happen
simple as that sh and uh yeah that was
bad every kitchen just has to have a
head chef running it since Franchesco
lost his he's been trying to do the job
himself I'll take this are you going to
serve it yes because
Jesus cook serve cook serve cook
serve it's a big mistake Franchesco is
not a train chef and he shouldn't even
be in the
kitchen keep on going he should be out
in the dining room Charming his
customers don't know how you all right
after all there are more staff in the
bloody kitchen than there are customers
in the dining room and not one of them
seems to be doing anything so you're
just cooking potatoes here yeah there
huge section and all you're cooking is
spuds you're out of order
yes Franchesco doesn't trust anyone to
do anything right bill on 11 and 12
right
[Music]
now octopus
another three
said all the best thank you very much
after you talk about a headless chicken
no wonder he's lost weight and customers
you you're working like a donkey I mean
you're hear everywhere and and trying to
run it overall one you're the most
amazing host you can charm the pants off
anyone um and you can sell good wine and
the short period of time I've been in
here today and one thing you I've come
to terms with is got to get out of the
kitchen the water tree got a mission
star after Franchesco have been here for
a year that's given to a restaurant on
the back of the consistency the
freshness of the ingredients keeping it
seasonal and the individual flare of the
chef but franchesco's lost the chef who
won the award if the standards have
slipped the inspectors will soon take
away that precious mishan star time to
check out the food because I um saw
lunch today from the kitchen I'm going
to go in the dining room now and have a
a bite to eat and I'd like you not to
present the menu but to show me three
dishes what represents the walnut tree
in with a michan star you can charge
top-notch prices but only if you provide
top-notch food I'm pretty confident you
like
[Music]
it porini and Palam lasna was always a
favorite here
B very
Bor you got to move on you got to search
and you got to evolve develop and create
excitement constantly when you're
charging these
prices main cause fish stew thank you
but the muscles haven't even been
cleaned we serve muscles in a
self-contained stew yeah they got to be
clean because when you serve it in like
this you can hear at the bottom there's
a lot of
grit sand so it's just like eating a
bowl of
play seasoned with
sand that is constantly grinding between
your teeth 28 of main course and
somewhat taking the
Mickey cuz if someone serve that in my R
I'd go [__]
berserk okay um I asked you earlier for
your best the best the best of Wales the
big buildup was for the classic Italian
fish you and sadly when it arrived
everything in that dish was overcooked
and why you piss off for a three-hour
break to style your hair and to have a
kit clean the [__]
muscles so we've hit rock bottom okay
yeah Welcome to the Real World tomorrow
we're going to pick ourselves back up
and start off with a clean
slate
it's my second day in Wales where I'm
trying to help the owner save the famous
mut Tree Restaurant it's got all sorts
of problems but it does still have a
Michelin star you don't get that without
a top chef but franchesco's lost his we
need to find another one fast hedf
criteria HF criteria young enthusiastic
firm ambition some of them keep you out
of the kitchen so just ride something
keeps me out of the kitchen and uh hello
r Ramsey U we' Got a list of ingredients
um we're just going to ask you to go
through and cook up something very
simple yeah thanks for the surprise Lads
that's all right always a surprise with
me salary starting salary starting
salary would say 23 always an
interesting question when you interview
a young Chef what salary you looking for
and they tell you within 30 seconds of
course what they're about what would you
be happy with as a starting celery I'd
be happy with 30 30 as a starting celery
[__] off out of it
do you want me to write it or do you
know how to write English no you
probably write English better than me
yeah well I I'll write it down you f it
through but you pay for it okay it's
expensive but it's very hard just to go
in there and just and just do it um 15
minutes yeah yeah interesting to see if
he uses all the ingredients whether he
puts the clams with a hadock with um the
onions or he does a nice tomato um a
rocket salad yeah something plain and
simple your mother could make
yeah it's just eating Ro
paste yeah boring sort kind of thing I
expect the misses to do yeah I thought
it was a little bit Plain Jane boring um
and certainly not worth 30 grand a year
that's for sure no but like that's the
ingredients you were given don't start
blaming your tools no no no no no take
it on the chin I I wouldn't have changed
it
though next up is Santa Roso second in
command at the holiday in in Swindon
could be a bandito could be a big
bandito let's shoot the
bandito what do you think
Maia Sant Gordon take a seat um very
well experienced man yeah yeah yeah I
like cooking you like cooking yeah I can
see that yeah what do you know about the
walnut tree nothing nothing at all
nothing at all don't about the history
uh the reputation no the missionary star
no no
so what
if you don't know anything about the
walnut tree yeah why did you come for
the job because I I say it's time for me
to change right um and what's the
current menu at the Swindon we have some
steak Yeah gam chicken and a lot of
microwave a lot of microwave microwave
microwave think of something magical
keep it simple oh yeah um and enjoy it
okay thank you
and where I'm thinking wow what kind of
flavor I want to I want to come up with
you
know and let's
[Music]
see very rare joke like that can cook
very rare
[Music]
M this a fantastic
one and just explain what they are
please yes this H I call it pasta fresa
pasta fresa pasta fresa fresh pasta with
vong and Salat mhm thank you with a
lemon juice mhm just nice and clean
just also that is paper yeah thank you
thank you very much felt like sneezing
there all that pepper
every Jesus Christ look that's just a
pine of stge there's nothing in there is
there he sad yeah he sad to see some
there also a c
c yeah I I found it yeah miles away from
what we wanted yeah um and um little bit
embarrassing really yeah cuz it was
below average
yeah £22,000 and I wouldn't even pay him
23,000
L even with the Michelin star it's going
to be hard to find a head chef in the
middle of Wales but I'm still Banning
Franchesco from the kitchen right now
was see water where's Franchesco yes sir
I really would appreciate it if you
don't come anywhere near the kitchen I
know how stubborn you
are and there step over that line stay
that
side thank
[Music]
you this way I'll get to know the team
better Blake is the most junior he just
come off the building site because the
weather's too
cold Spike he's here on work
experience Kevin's a waiter and handyman
he's been here since the old days and
knew the walnut tree in its prime hello
Kevin hello G how are you yeah obviously
with that accent local boy very from
abeni yes I am do you like a laugh and a
joke or I no I just yeah just love hard
work definitely be evil like we all yeah
be
evil J's a local boy very ambitious and
King to get on but Franchesco says he's
not a team
player so that's my secret I'll stay
back on there put a pck on
that
and Stefan is the most experienced Chef
Franchesca won't let him run the kitchen
but I want to see what he's made of so
I'm going to put him in charge it's a
normal lunch service and franchesco's
wife andri has brought some friends in
for a bite to eat kitchen's in your
hands now you got to come out you got to
start talking and start propelling the
Brigade and bringing it together let's
go no no turn around and address the
Brigade that's
it chicken plus chips for four kids one
crab one and dive two follow one lo lo
of pork two chicken and one
rockhead I need some chips for these
chickens yeah can't step too quiet the
only person I can to hear now is Gary
and you're running the kitchen let's go
okay garnish Blakey where the [__]
Blakey Blakey the window what are you
doing 5D
yes I need an answer guys I wonder
jica's back in the kitchen his family
are still waiting for their
lunch everything's out there now
everyone's standing staring at their
food two people haven't got it come
on come on Steph let's go this is a
[__]
disaster okay chicken how
long Stefano how long chip yeah you know
this is for it's for the boss's wife you
know that touch it Stone old yeah get
another one
in hey he owns the place and I'm not
going to serve that let's go look for
the chicken
got ready let's go bring it together
let's
go nice and hot this time send it the
food is late and cold Stefan can't
organized chips for a 4-year-old okay
right come here just stop everybody yeah
I mean stop come here you come here shut
up shut up I'm talking that was a
disaster complete disaster the food
standing hang around the past nothing
happening and you're over there and then
just you I'm sorry but it's not good
enough you're not nothing's coming out
okay stop now okay you take over and see
if we can pull ourselves together a
little bit and get ourselves out of the
[__] because in 15 minutes this place is
going to be the biggest [__] hole in
Wales you shut it okay back in your
corner and listen to what's going on do
you hear what I said yeah do it right
let's go
little clear down yeah clear down first
okay Gary you know where we are yes and
theill you decide exactly what you want
doing in your mind 2 minutes before we
dress you turn around and addess the
Brigade and tell them exactly what you
want yeah uh one bra beef one venison
sausage one Grill one
tuna hey let's give it together hey we a
team and I don't want it back in here
telling us we can't [__] do it again
okay so we have teamwork now yeah if he
can't hear you then don't scoon for that
okay cuz we're not a oneman
band check two covers one pigon one
oysters one RI one
duck go can you go with the scolars
one Gary is a real arrogant little
[__] but at least he can speak unlike
Stefano they can't even run a [__]
bath let alone a [__] kitchen I need
the tun first off you please
and you got three chips yeah yeah we
three chips and one Tom Sal
please good well done good okay well
done well done a man course it's bloody
difficult to get out like that you know
well done yesing a few more people how'
It Go for
you thank you for being honest I thought
it went
terrible huh really bad you really do
have a problem talking to individuals
you know that and today was a
disaster yeah I'm sorry it really was a
disaster if you ever get your own
restaurant one day make sure you haven't
got any more than [__] five seats
because you won't be able to manage you
know
that and so we got to Now work on this
in the next couple of days and stop you
being a cook and look at the important
role of becoming a
[Music]
chef there are still problems in the
kitchen but I just don't understand why
there's so few
[Music]
customers these days they serve around
300 customers a week the previous owner
Franco used to serve 800 I'd love to
know what happened to the missing
500 have you heard of the walnut tree
yes oh yeah when was the last time you
were there it was Franco's last meal
just workships one yeah have you ever
heard of the walnut tree overpriced
overpriced and how many times were you
there oh very very frequently when he
was there because he was open all hours
you turn up at 11:00 at night and be
assured of a very good welcome do you
think he's missed now now he's no longer
there I think so they're not as
good not recently since has been taken
over now since Franchesca took over the
walnut tree nine new restaurants have
opened nearby if people think his place
is too expensive they've got plenty of
Cheaper Al Alternatives morning ladies
so we've been there when Franco mhm it
seems to be everyone's favorite now of
any Franco and an they always seem to be
the Darlings of abig gaven yet no one's
been since Franchesca took over three
years
ago maybe there's a lesson to be learned
if your customers won't pay top whx cut
your prices otherwise mad they'll eat
elsewhere and you come down to the plat
of Freedom Think Jesus is that a typing
error 70 quid it is somewhat a little
bit intimidating because it's so
expensive
which puts people off and have we gone
up in price over the last three years
have we got more and more expensive yeah
probably the plateau for the was 55 60 0
60 and then I push it to 65 and only in
the last two months I put it to 70
because the price of the fish is going
up and
up as usual Franchesco thinks he knows
best but I won't give him a bollin in
front of his team anyway just now I've
got other fish to
fry
there's still no head chef so far I
think Stefano and Gary are the best
candidates but Franchesco just won't
consider them is it's he's got to be
realistic he's in the middle of Wales
not London straight forward and if we
don't find anyone as good as Gary or we
don't find anyone as good as Stefano
then you know we're going to look at
what we've got
internally H well
well no I think that I think we need a
somebody really from outside and inside
internally I can only be the one
Franchesco just doesn't see it but Gary
and Stefano have talent and I'm going to
show him ready the only way I'll get him
to try their food is to make him believe
that I've cooked it really important
tomorrow night yeah big night for you um
f doesn't believe that you're capable of
um becoming the chef I think you are
it's your half hour so have you thought
about your dishes think of an oyster Stu
with like herb crush the grat on the top
for main course I was thinking a meat of
some sort like fet with some some shots
MH so important we'll do service then at
the end of service we'll sit them down
and bang you let rip [__] you let rip
big time uh right Stefano let's
go the crap in the kitchen about the
delegation the lack of Direction yeah we
can work on that that's workable but
this is your half hour of magic all
right think about it yeah and and and
and and make sure you utilize that time
and come up with something magical then
we'll sit him down for dinner and we'll
say eat the following this is me this is
me on a plate yeah right hard on
material how do you say erection Italian
erection ere okay ere de man
okay [__] me it's Posh word from
as well as preparing their meals Gary
and Stefan must do their normal kitchen
duties straight away Stefan starts
working with the team but Gary He's only
interested in his own
meal even I think that's too
ambitious uh Gary 2
seconds you've had a bit more time on
your hands this morning to get ready he
hasn't done anything for tonight so we
swap over yeah okay so once all these
vegetables cooked then I want you in the
kitchen concentrating on tonight
concentrate on the canop for tomorrow
night and then you take 2 hours yeah
enough yeah yeah 2 hours they organize
for
tonight I really thought Gary had great
potential to be a good head chef but
quite honestly he doesn't give a [__]
about his team he just cares about
himself and selfish individuals don't
make great head
[Music]
chefs Franchesco and enrio think I'm the
chef tonight if Gary and Stefan haven't
prepared it'll be my reputation that
suffers what's in here bread drums
cheese F and cheese uh parsley tastes
nice yeah tastes quite and Steph what
have you got
um
M stop being nosing yeah you concentrate
on your own food stop being noing that
little VI there it's not a competition
it's not a competition at all don't be
sing okay inside is what is a d
chestnuts duck and chestnuts yeah
Stefano's duck and Chestnut ravioli
shows real
imagination no I like the um the sweet
you feel you can taste something sweet
is that's nice
chest I like the way present it and
Franchesco approves of Gary's oysters
very nice stano Gary yeah look so far so
good clean place for me it's a sign of
yeah happiness yes pleas play it's
good for the main course Gary's cooked
phet steak and Stefano Cass nice both of
you well
done
happy aot happy still can't even talk to
me yet right go Kevin whatever you do
don't drop those okay well done guys yes
I like the colors I'm sure I like the
taste okay um Stefan you ready with the
pancake
you're happy now aren't you hey I never
SE so happy yeah it's about Bloody time
[Music]
huh hi
guys okay yes yes supper supper I really
like the ravioli of dark and Chestnut
yes um and I like everything else
interesting for me yes I would say most
of the dishes do were exciting I was
interested in the in the Yoli which
again I found it exciting and very good
very nicely done and the beef and the
beef uh I would have like half a do
underneath the beef some form of
potatoes some form of potatoes that
would have BR the dishes up and balanc
it out uh don't take this the wrong way
but I didn't cook any dish all right
oysters beef SB yeah was his menu 24
hours ago yes duck ravoli Cass and
pancakes were Stefanos and because they
weren't been interviewed during the week
because I think Franchesco doesn't think
they're good enough I wanted them to
cook three dishes each for you both to
have dinner tonight so I didn't touch
anything thank you very much for your
comments thank
you okay uh Gary two seconds
step um well that was interesting
tonight yeah all the dishes that you
both done he said was capable of going
on the menu great because for me it went
very well both you came up trumps and if
he wasn't going to consider you for the
job then I was
yeah
it's day four I'm halfway through my
time at the Warner Tree Franchesco the
owner has been stubbornly resisting my
suggestions we still need to find a head
chef and with a70 main course of the
menu I'm determined to make him lower
his prices if it continues being as
quiet as it
is are you going to look to try and
bring the prices down a touch to create
something new about the walmut tree to
get people back in here no I don't want
to go down down and on on the cheap side
because have you got a [__] Choice
I'm not talking to asking you to open
the doors and become a happy eer they
spent 37 years getting the business to
where it is today of course you're
spending 3 years and it's sadly on the
decline what I'm trying to say is you
bring a new traffic coming through the
door and you tweak the prices to
establish the confidence and once you
got the confidence then over a period of
five or six years yes you turn the
volume up on the justification of what
you're doing not convinced I would say
I'm not con
sorry it's me you shouldn't be so
stubborn try
it if you've got the food and those C
customers are coming through the door
and they're generating sales the asset
is the is the wine is the wine which who
can sell that me excellent so the
chances are far greater to do it that
way than to do it the way you're doing
it
currently in a way yes yes [__]
Hallelujah welcome back welcome back
where the [__] have you been where
nobody go in the
want please try it I do I'll do it man
please no problem thank God franchesco's
finally agreed to one of my
ideas and there's more good news at last
a candidate for the head Chef's job with
a good pedigree and you feel now at the
age of 26 that you've worked in the last
two establishments as a sue Chef you're
now ready for your first head Chef's job
yeah I'm I'm sort of getting to the
point where I'm in the kitchen I've got
my own ideas the way I want to run
things um okay obviously some um
mushrooms rocket gorgona grain mustard
garlic fresh um tlell parmesan cheese
see you in 15 minutes than you
Spencer bed of tomato salad the tacelli
of mushroom sort of like carbonara
almost the lini and I'm thinking like a
light rock fur and um rocket salad s on
top if I've got
time no one expect any to come in in uh
12 minutes and Shout
time Spencer Ralph has traveled all the
way from London this would be his first
head Chef's job but he has worked in a
mission St
restaurant he looks strong in impression
is yes I like the idea of being 26
someone young someone vibrant someone
you can push yeah definitely so M so at
26 if if he's not hungry now when he's
never going to be here yeah thank you
it's a a rocket and tomato salad mhm
with mushroom carbonara and poached
hadock mhm thank you very much it looks
neat yeah
yeah flavor is there mhm like tell looks
nice it's not um looks beautifully
cooked it's not stuck together it's not
ConEd
um he's listened to the
brief he kept it simple yeah yeah what
he has shown in the last 15 minutes the
guy can cook no the flavors are there
flavors are there exactly that sit down
SP how do you feel running a
establishment um with the m
star it's a little bit daunting you know
to do it the first time but I'm yeah a
little bit but I'm also you know it's
what I've always sort of aimed for it's
always what I wanted you know and I sort
of feel confident as well as scared at
the same time thank you very much thank
you I hope Spencer accepts the job if he
can start work soon there's a slim
chance the walnut tree can save its
Michelin
star almost everyone is looking happier
and it's so important to find the right
person to gel with those two guys
especially Gary cuz there you've got one
little ballsy rockweiler that really
wants this job and you're not prepared
to give him the opportunity
no I hope we found a great head
chef now I want to change the atmosphere
in the dining room it's too cold and
formal we need to bring back some of the
rustic charm that people loved in the
old
days let's hope Franchesco agrees the
first reaction I would say no but
flexible in the kitchen I want to see
more energy and more get up and go stay
on Focus so and G wants to say something
you you're up here listening ready to
say yes or no not on the floor
cockroaches live on the floor you're not
a [__] cockroach even with that
hairstyle you stillo not cockroach t on
schot in first lightly seasoned everyone
needs to know when the food's good
enough to leave the kitchen even Blake
it
salt that's all you Tes nothing lunch
time cooking in out a microwave like an
absolute [__] donkey but not cook you
weren't actually tasting anything you're
just pressing buttons takeing out put it
on the plate it's got the Miss from sty
this establishment you're going to have
to learn how to taste prop and
understand what a balance of flavor is
about we're going to make a chef for you
you know that if it kills me we're going
to make a chef for you know that good
how the [__] how I don't know but I'm
thinking about it now
yeah Kevin's been here years so he can
tell me if the atmosphere is more like
it used to
be uh this looks nice and just breaking
up and it's not just a dull old boring
yeah let's start it's been like it for
years Le CL have you done any oh you
have y apparently people used to come
for lunch and stay for hours spending
even more money we need to get back that
relaxed family feeling what
big difference and cozy which is the
most important thing and that's what was
missing welcome it yeah more welcome
looks fantastic Kevin's done a great job
redecorating we need one last touch to
restore those old traditions if
Franchesca will agree to it and you know
what I think the entrance needs a
picture of you and
Franco no the old generation passing on
to the the new generation I think
franchesco's finally seen the
light day
and despite the hangovers it's straight
back to business today is a big day the
walnut tree is 40 years old this month
and franchesco's thrown a
party I think he should invite Franco
and Anne the previous owners they're
vital part of the restaurant's history
there is one thing I want you to do for
me yes which you're not going to like I
know you're not going to like because
you're going to um disagree but I really
think is important um I want you to
bring Franco back and I want you to talk
to him I can see already in your face
you don't want to do it I don't have to
say anything my expression says says
everything I think the first minute
frankco walks in here it will silence
the rumors and it will cut the [__]
out and it will start encouraging the
locals to come back the message is
telling him that you want to maintain
what he's built that's what I'm fighting
for I'm fighting for the reputation of
the war three more than
mine thank you thank you Franco and an
we're here for 37 y yes Franchesca has
been here for three 37 plus 3 is 40 yeah
massive celebration huge celebration 40
Years of History yes you going to put it
back on the map lift it alongside that I
think there's 80 90 guests coming along
we have really nice exciting canopies
Stefano y can you
Corell can you quell give me an answer
straight away don't take two week H not
that nice but not that nice we going to
learn again right watch quick as you can
in Twisted Spoon round before it cools
down yeah before it cools
down and then heat the chocolate mousse
the back of the pal hand again yeah and
then it slides
off okay go
go not bad not bad not bad not bad for
the first time not bad not bad a little
bit too much on there again again oh
over the last few days I realized that
Stefano is really talented it's a shame
he's just so
shy in and out oh that's good that's
very good
right in and out too slow and
again come here don't throw the tow so
early in and out again so far Stan's
beating you on the other hand Gary
thinks he's the dog's balls but he's not
nearly as good a
cook be kind please don't put yours next
to
m stay
there and I done I got this hat made
special you know that now you're at home
now you can cook your heart out your
hair is perfect all nice and spiky and
all the girls never ready still want to
Shag
you tonight's party is make a break for
Franchesco he's on the verge of going
bust and he must start filling the
restaurant
again a bit you know it's obviously it's
going to be a very emotional evening for
for me and uh and the rest of the
customer that is going to come here and
for one especially franus and um work it
work then I will it's your place this
time and you're proud to show this off
certainly and after all this yes
Fresco's invited 80 of the great and
good of
abeni everyone's just got to love
everything and if they tell all their
friends the food is as good as ever then
Franchesco could soon serve 800 people a
week just like the good old days just
run it for me run it for me mhm what
what was that rotta
rotta get out get out get out get
[Music]
out well yes what's the
feedback they're all loving it they're
all loving it yeah yeah we've all been
waiting for Franco and an to arrive
hopefully this will prove that
Franchesco is carrying on the Traditions
they established at the walnut
tree I would love to I'm going out to
dinner
[Laughter]
tonight
[Music]
I'm very glad that you came here both of
you and uh to celebrate this special
event for both of us for all of us thank
you for pleas should we do it together
yes happy birthday happy
[Music]
birthday I wish I
was
way
[Applause]
it's been a terrific night I just hope
it marks the start of the walnut trees
Revival I just wanted to say thank you
very much everybody because uh without
you it wouldn't have happened and uh I
really appreciate your hard work thank
you thank you
all
ofk on my final day another breakthrough
Spencer's accepted the head Chef's job
okay Spencer thank you very much
indeed bye bye for now and you sounded
excited yes very much so yes and I'm
excited see fantastic that's quite uh
refreshing it's a relief yeah yeah it
was very happy very happy excellent
good there's only one more thing
Franchesco needs to sort out with
Spencer arriving as head chef there can
only be one second Chef Stefano or Gary
one can stay but one must go Gary he so
ambitious I'm not sure he'd give Spencer
the support he needs how would you feel
if you're brought a new head chef now
well I mean I'm I could say before I'm
not upset about it but um if franchisco
feels the need to do it then I'm GL
going to learn for whoever comes in if
they got something to teach me but then
again if if they if they're no good or
if they're just as slow or or awkward to
it with stano I'm just going to push on
and still get ahead of them and prove
him wrong pretty much and so even if a
new Chef came in I'm still going to give
him a run for the money yeah yeah
under Franco what Spencer needs in a
number two is a chef who combines
teamwork and cooking ability and youf
may be arriving all right yeah it is
clearly obvious that both you and Gary
can't stay one of you would have to
go and I think you should
stay well to see that when the new head
chef arrives I think it's going to be a
good recipe for success but we need to
keep that authenticity of that Italian
style that rustic feel of the wet tree
that's you don't know what what will
happen you want to stay here don't you
well I would like to stay
here it something change
here it's a hard decision though Gary
and Stefano both have things going for
them I'm convinced Stefano would make a
better second chef but will franches
agree I doubt it well that was
interesting yeah one thing I have
learned over the last few days is they
can't work together total impossibility
okay definitely definitely not
but they can cook and they can put food
on the plate but coming together as a
team you know they haven't got enough
respect for one another but one will
have to go one definitely has to go my
my my big concern is Gary is not a team
player but someone like Stefano would
sit and be a great number two you worked
with him both yeah which one would you
have to get rid of well in this case uh
I have to go for
G at last franches and I agree on
something Stefan should stay as spener
number two and Gary should
go I'll leave Franchesco to sort that
one out that's done constru I'm
off bye guys you guys continue talking
all right yes don't stop you stay at the
kitchen please yeah continue working on
those customers yes I will yeah keep on
talking to Franco by means yeah good man
I'll be back in a month's time okay um
just before I go one little
present a special gift one of those
filthy barnacled muscles they serve me
on my first day bye guys see you in a
month's time thanks
[Music]
[Applause]
a it's February and I'm back in Wales to
visit the walnut tree in
a month ago I spent a week here trying
to turn things around and let me tell
you it was a hell of a
week I found a renowned restaurant going
bust
boring very boring it needed a new head
chef very rare a joke like that can cook
very rare M hard Graft in the kitchen
you shut it okay back in your corner and
listen to what's going on do you hear
what I said do it cheaper food Jesus is
that a typing error 70 quid and more
customers it was in danger of losing his
illustrous reputation not to mention his
precious Mission star got the mission
star this establishment you're going to
have to learn how to taste prop and
understand what BAL of flavors
about now I'm back to see what's changed
the 2004 Michelin guide was published a
few weeks ago sadly the Warner Tree lost
its star yeah very well sorry to hear
about the mission star yeah big blow
that one we get it back going to get it
back qu going to say the yeah Spencer
yam Spen has been here for two weeks but
with no head Che for nearly a year it
was pretty obvious they'd lose their
star hi Spen morning okay you well yeah
not bad down yeah stead Ste BR one over
so now the question is does Spencer have
the ambition to win it back what about
the missig STA need less pressure
because now I just got to get back up
they can St your yeah mark on it you can
now rebuild it um and take the prise for
it down the line as opposed to yeah at
least I can say then it's mine and I've
not taken it over and gives you a chance
to change things as well yes because
nothing's setting Stone now sure
yeah nice very good huh looking very
clean very vibrant and um table 15 that
looks lovely huh two salmon lunch two no
starters two roast beef one fish cake
one lasagna they're all lunch that's a
small one yeah has he managed to stay
out the kitchen um yes and he hasn't
come in with his jacket on not
yet that's good news you don't want him
back in the kitchen do you no no no
that's why I've made desserts more
difficult so he doesn't know what he's
doing yeah that's why I had to change
the menu straight away one soup one
mozzarella two chicken both
lunch moving hey vibrant action
Hey Kevin sorry come back shouting um
communication and then just a drizzle of
lemon fantastic of course it's fantastic
food's looking nice food is looking nice
and we're improving every day so it it
feels more together already in that
short period of time because he's
commanding the kitchen they follow him
that's the most important thing the I'm
surprised to see Gary still in the
kitchen I thought he was too ambitious
to fit in have you been told off yet uh
no I can't [__] wait to hear how that
goes down you know that no never going
actually I was late I was late for work
you were late and did he give you a
bollin oh yes he pined me to the floor
and beat me up fantastic fantastic
fantastic it turns out Stefan is the one
to leave he said he's found the change
is hard to
take I'm quite jealous of Spencer
because he's allowed to
do
everything and things that I couldn't
even think about it when I just arrived
and uh
that's one of the thing that makes me go
away because it's it's painful for me to
to see what's going on I wonder how Gary
feels about Stefan's decision to leave
so
um Stefan is leaving yeah was that you
who pushed him out no it wasn't me that
pushed him out no I see as if um Spencer
has been given the opportunity to do
whatever he likes change the menu
rearrange the kitchen been given all the
opportunities and be able to go ahead
with it yeah which is a bit of a
surprise which is a bit of a surprise uh
Franchesco never let Stefano do any of
that he always had a saying what was
going on and how the how everything
developed yeah and now see Spencer doing
all these different things now and I see
know how hard it was for him to actually
take control of the kitchen it was
difficult does that upset you it hasn't
upset me so much I think it's upset
Stefano more than me but you were
stronger than Stefano yeah some of us
got to survive than the others m sorry
there's no room I'm genuinely sorry that
Stefan is leaving but I'm thrilled
franchesco's back where he belongs
Charming the
customers the dining room is busy and
vibrant just like the old walnut tree
now it'll make sure you put this on the
wall look nice little momentum so when
the customers come through they can see
those four happy smiling faces yeah
yeah there's a new force in the kitchen
in other words a new and a new Force
outside because that's that's where I
belong being outside and be able to
explain and be confident in what I'm
explaining to the
customers regain that confident that was
once lost bye-bye thank you very
much enjoy it then I really do hope that
this place gets back to where it was
it's a phenomenal restaurant you got a
great owner beautiful dining room great
kitchen and let's get it back
on
track yeah and Spence what do you want
to do over the next two years what's
your ambition at the wner tree over the
next two years to beat the reputation it
had before you're 26 years of age I was
26 when I got my first HF
job I'm now at the age of 37 11 years on
it was the most important job in my
entire life at the age of 26 so good
luck Chia CH ciao thank you guys thank
you yes see bye guys the future is
definitely looking brighter for
Francesco if he sticks to what I told
him he can make the walnut tree famous
again and win back that Michelin star
this week I'm trying to save more Place
restaurant oh [__] it now the dining
room's empty where is everybody and the
food is shocking that's a your buddy
that is a pile of ship I'll have to deal
with possibly the worst waiter in the
world oh Zach I'm [__] crazy Frenchman
you're being a little [__] again and a
chef obsessed with deep fat friers if
Mark bangs on again about the
justification to why I should accept
that he cooks 99% of his food in a
[__] deep fat fryer I'll put one up
his ass
sideways drop
PE Isa in the home
counties full of stock Brokers ladies
who lunch and
golfers 35,000 rounds of golf are played
every year on isa's moreplay golf course
that should be more than enough to keep
the attached restaurant full but none
other golfers ever G
nor does anyone
else I've never seen such a sorry
looking dining
room I have just the weed to turn the
place around and that's a tall
order Jesus Christ a might monstrosity
um First Impressions yeah um I turn it
into an open prison for young offenders
cuz it looks [__]
ghastly God I think this could be my
toughest job
[Applause]
yet I've come to try out the food more
purple everywhere but the place is
deserted looks like I'm ding alone not a
good
[Music]
sign God knows what they're going to
serve
me the cam bear deep fried camon bear
have I gone back in time dear Lord for
what we're about to receive may I not be
poisoned for the fourth time in 4
months amen
Jesus it reminds me of rented fish
fingers that's disgusting thank God I've
got some wine to wash it down God dear
dear it absolutely stinks it's
caught where is
everybody still at least I can be sure
no one's watching
me
next up huge huge dange I have gone back
in time it's the colorly equivalent of
flared trousers it's the meal all right
then this duck tastes like it grew up in
the 1970s it's not exactly [__]
tender is it popular the dish duck
orange not really no have a little
taste it's quite tough no that's really
difficult to e yeah I know you should
always spit out no are you going to
swallow yeah
R
water it's still in there mhm you're
still oh my God don't swallow
it horrible food no wonder this place is
in
trouble clueless completely
clueless but on the verge of been
embarrassing so what do you think about
your meal tonight or
for I'm lost for words almost
nail well at least I wasn't poisoned so
I've come back to meet the owners of
this 1970s
nightmare trying to be nice huge place
Richard hudon and Nick White House have
sunk all their money into this place and
it's been a
disaster it's like an old country House
hotel isn't it like a historic it was
someone's house this empty room will be
costing them nearly £100 an hour for
staff and overheads all your potential
has it was fantastic it's got character
it used to be a successful bur in in the
days when states were Posh they used to
do 200 200 250 covers a day here Valet
Park King probably last time we took his
real money wasn't probably the only
restaurant on the High Street yeah
absolutely aren't they ashamed to be
still serving the same food from the
Burnie in
days and who's got the food background I
neither of us to our back our background
is drink um I spent 15 years in the
licensed trade Richard sacrificed
everything to buy this place if I can't
help him his family could be homeless I
should have done this in my 20s when I
didn't have children and didn't have uh
a huge mortgage and and everything else
we sat there and thought shall we do it
shall we do it and a few Dark Nights
when we thought maybe it's a bit risky
and there's a lot of risk involved for
us both Nicks put everything he's got
into the business as
well Running a Restaurant is completely
different from selling drinks no wonder
the kitchen is such a night man he h
best irve was a French head chef when
they took
over but no one liked his cooking
including
me we gave people some shocking experien
I think it's safe to say well we we
taught them what the extremes were like
people can be quite emotional about food
and you've ruined my life that type of
thing I know how they feel um engine
room kitchen yeah good afternoon let's
meet the rest of the kitchen team and
Mar Robinson Markt Robinson calls
himself the executive chef whatever that
means so you're a head chef somewhere
else before you came here I trained as a
chef and then um became very
disillusioned went I and got an IT and
business degree
gave up cooking for a business degree
doesn't sound very passionate about food
to
me he was brought in to sort things out
but all he's done is spend thousands of
pounds on microwaves and friers and piss
her off come on strawberry French
man good and he said he doesn't like
you there are two people in the dining
room let's see if their lunch is as bad
as my dinner
almost everything seems to be deep fried
and the oil smells like it hasn't been
changed for months when you walk through
the restaurant the first thing you can
smell is like um tainted sort of fried
smell fried smell almost a little bit
like hospital food
yes chef why ISO feel the saladas it's
like kind of saladas but is yeah how
many new potatoes around uh only one one
new potato yeah fu roel for £950 any
olives no nothing's ready here no beans
cooked no eggs cooked what the [__] is
going on oh we just in the [__] cuz we
got two customers for lunch this kitchen
is a nightmare Mark was brought in to
update the food but I can't see what
he's done how can he get away with a
menu like this and how would you um how
would you describe the style the food um
it's
um the the the the alart stuff that we
do it's very um it's very much here a
steak and three sources you can have
with it it's not a great it's not a
massive detraction for what they were
serving before here and three sources of
what uh Brandy and mushrooms Stilton and
bacon and peppercorn Jesus those three
sauces sound a little bit burish well
they are I mean this is the thing it's a
bit it's a bit 1976 you can say that
again little n sauce straight out in the
microwave still in the mushroom it's an
insult to cooking oh in a bag damn no
wonder we need so many [__]
microwaves work thank [__] I'm not
hungry parley hey come on would be the
same without that P come on get it on
there there you go good old Bernie I
know you love your parsley and so far
they need a [__] rock up their ass
because if they continue the way they
are doing now it's going to go down like
a sack of [__] and quite frankly I don't
think they actually care about customers
and every dining room needs to care
about customers otherwise they don't
come [__]
back it's my second day in Isa where I'm
trying to help the more Place restaurant
and golf
club the food stuck in the
70s be as usual there are no customers
today how book for lunch none nothing
and tonight none so but we did have
someone come in to look at the
restaurant it's either here or TJ eyes
[__] hell I'd rather go to TJ eyes
Mart Robertson the executive chef should
be tearing his hair out he's taking the
day off chickens but you look different
out your
whes you look like a monk on
leave thanks I'm going to play golf
later around going to play golf we're
supposed to be running an empty restant
to get it off the ground to get it
moving towards something semi decent not
[__] around on a golf course at least
he knows there's something wrong because
he's hired a new head chef now there are
three talk about too many cooks one's a
joke Frenchman the other's stuck in the
70s I hope Andy TR from the 21st century
you really got your work cut out there I
know and you can't go in with all guns
blazing booting them all in the GH in
the first 24 hours you'll have no one
left I know I know how would you how
would you play this situation narrow the
menu down to begin with yeah start off
really simple yeah um and and and look
what's going on locally Andy looks
promising but I have to show him what
he's up against what is that Andy huh it
looks like something out of another what
is
that Jesus right painful it's like a
dehydrated silicon implant actually it's
a microwave frozen deep fried burger
what is that this is a salad looks like
a plate of worms got it breaks my heart
when I see this [__] you know that do
you think that's nice
it's not bad Andy's worked at some
really good places he's going to need
all his experience I know I no it's
instantly some B sauce in a jar they
don't use that though do they ask our
executive chef Mark that he's as shocked
as I am B this ready made packet food
lazy cooking and it's more expensive
than making it fresh and it smell that
that's what the smell is Downs the
dining room yeah I mean on a Sunday I
bet you can smell it all over the
building Jesus Christ right down your H
Street no Wonder's no [__]
customers yes you're being a little
[__] again how come we have a
Frenchman here and we're buying French
dressing in little
[__] I'm impressed so far with Andy he
seems Keen to make changes and this yeah
this is what I want to get away and they
put it on the menu as Brussel Pate or
Brussels with chicken yeah it's just
plastic crap yeah now they're definitely
left on the burning in [__] hell
Frozen Yorkshire pudding oh lovely Andy
could be the chef I've been looking for
and that means I can get out of the
kitchen and work with the
owners it looks like a deceased Bridge
Club why spend £10,000 painting the
building a horrible color and nothing on
improving the food the reason for doing
it was to show people that the place had
changed s that it was very different at
night though we lighted up with purple
lighting it looks fantastic but it has
probably alienated some of our old Core
Business most important thing is to
focus on the food and get the food up to
where it should be what we should be
offering local how we should be um
selling the food um and and bringing in
a bit of a bit of a bargain I'm taking
Richard down the High Street to find out
where his ex- customers are
eating can't believe how close together
all the restaurant are really on one
High Street Isa is made up of wealthy
City types ladies at lunch and
surprisingly thousands of Americans who
work for a big conglomerate in the area
and red peppers packed yeah lady that
drinking champagne yeah spend behead Lun
15 15 20 but he's churning all the time
you know there's a good example yeah
very good Richard's a businessman and I
want him to see how much money these
places are taken there are 23
restaurants on the High Street so
competition is
fierce but I bet most people don't even
know there's a restaurant at more place
Big Challenge I'm going to ask a family
going to stop them and say have you
heard of more place do you know what it
is do you know where it is um come and
try us for lunch have you heard of more
place no have you heard of more place
unfortunately not you haven't you heard
a more place up the road there have you
been have you used the place before no I
don't like the camer you don't you it
strikes you it's been an isol another
purple building there it's a funeral
director you didn't copy that didn't you
what place well before they painted it's
um a strange color right you're not a
fan of the color if we painted
differently tomorrow would you come back
next week
yeah I'm going to get I get two brushes
you can have one of them and I'll have
the
other so in a survey on the
color I think this Trip's opened his
eyes to the potential of his own
restaurant he's given me an idea for the
new menu the plan is to give the
restaurant a new Direction and get
people talking about more place now you
know the deep fried [__] has to go and
um the passing around the plates and the
chopped tomato and that that that's
[__] 70s crap at its best Gordon I
have no desire to spend the rest of my
working day smelling of fat there
there's you know thousands of Americans
that live locally that um is the most
amazing Market to tap into there's no
reason why you can't have not an
American themed restaurant but an
American influence but get the place
famous for two or three dishes sure when
someone's driving past oh Christ look
there's more place you know they've got
the best burger in isia yeah who gives a
[__] it's a talk Point whether it's the
best burger whether it's the best
Childer it doesn't matter but as usual
Mark has a problem my concern is how
that go down with um any of the older
CLE on until that they've got that com
okay is is that keeping the business
aoat would that no no there you go no
disrespect you I've gotone inters before
where everyone's been nervous about the
existing old farty boring bastards that
sit there and take a twoe holiday in
between courses and dribble throughout
the Viagra coming with a cof they no
we're looking for new vibrant young
exciting customers that are going to be
led to this place for the next 10 years
can we [__] off in the kitchen now
absolutely
stay focused One Direction American
Style Cafe upbeat friendly service
bloody good food um and stick to it and
if Mark bangs on again about the
justification to why I should accept
that he cooks 99% of his food in a
[__] deep fat fryer and to either
spend what 125,000 on six [__]
microwaves I'll put one up his ass
[Music]
sideways uh why don't we do a couple of
burgers up for Richard and Nick my
organic Burger made with totally fresh
ingredients is miles away from Mark deep
fried crap nothing wrong with a burger
when it's done like this lovely
oh welcome to proper
cooking and it's cheaper to make than
bought in Silicon implants tomato chuty
it's a nice raw cherry tomato chuty with
shalots put a little bit of Parmesan on
toast them the celebration Burger
lovely
so far Nick and Richard have shown
little interest in the food they're
[Music]
serving what's the
verdict that fantastic it is absolutely
brilliant and that is just that's the
talking point that is I at at more place
and the burgers are awesome you got to
go there and have one fresh
me and because burgers are Ally so badly
done what an opportunity to really
Excel I can almost see them counting the
money they could make with my American
theme burgers and corn beef hash peacon
pie Peach melbour and smoked Havoc
Chowder the most important thing about
this particular soup is you know it's
done up in the morning clam Chow made up
we're using potatoes the clam juice to
thicken it we've gone a little step
further and poached some qu's eggs then
pour the Chowder over the hadock over
the
clams the qu leg still nice and running
inside that's everything and you take a
spoon you think oh [__] it up that's
moish the food is really coming together
this is the corn be passion with holiday
finished with pomy mustard not difficult
at all not at all exception
really finally we're getting somewhere
now all we need is some
customers 35,000 golfers use this place
every bloody year you know that and
there's a small of them actually get in
to that Bloody restaurant through there
so the idea now is going around there
stalking them a little bit on the green
and asking them to taste this amazing
food I'm taking Kim one of the
waitresses and Andy to entice them in
with the food morning sir how you doing
we like a quick
Burger so there we are thank you very
much what in what's this in Aid of this
a of Handy new Chef in the restaurant at
more place are you we haven't used that
ien been that place for 3 years four
years joh I used to come down here on a
Sunday and we booked a breakfast and we
had a tea booked and he just took so
long to get the breakfast out really
that's interesting well we we had to tea
off and had to leave the breakfast and I
ain't been in there since Nick and
Richard can't keep an empty restaurant
going forever we have to fill the dining
room and make customers come back this
is a beautiful mini hamburger with a
nice fresh tomato chutney on top uh
charcoal grilled would you be so kind to
have a quick taste and just give us a
little insight yeah pleasure this
gorgeous this is gorgeous why's going to
go mad now look it's stood all down your
jumper he can I wonder how many these
golfers are ex customers toast the brand
in it is trying to get people into the
restaurant try my good food is there a
theme to your menu chower um great
Burgers corn beef hash uh beautiful
roast um Nica glories would you come
back to the
restant there are three days of the year
when all restaurants however bad are
full New Year's Eve Valentine's night
and Mother's Day this one what are you
doing on Mother's Day that's a good good
point it's Mother's Day this Sunday and
it could be make or break for more plays
or maybe book a table for Mother's Day
that's this weekend Sunday here campai
it's uh slightly heavier on the run
which makes it a little bit special this
is nice this is possibly try us out one
day we will try you
out three down
34,99 to
go hopefully we've enticed some
disgruntled customers back and made some
new converts my next task to sort out
the weight
it's Friday night and time is running
out for practicing on customers all nine
of
them it's Andy's night off and so Mar's
running the
kitchen I just want you know Peter it's
not Square just Square them up so why is
he in the dining room idea I just want
them straight tonight I want to see if
the waiters can push the new menu on a
bed of spinach topped with a fried egg
oh well that that sounds great actually
it is nice I tried it yesterday changed
well done Kim one corn beef hash let's
but on the spinach next time okay quick
smoke H CH which is a soup it's with
with with a uh come on
Peter he's got H fish he's got he's got
what was that
EG no the customers know more than him
can I have the cam bear two of those
please oh God they've ordered the camon
bear
chest up hey ja looks so shy I'm not
sure he can walk and talk at the same
time your [__] security guard never
mind sell the new menu there you go
that's it you
started it's a bit cold now things are
going wrong in the kitchen as well Mark
can't even make the deep fried cam bear
it's frozen I thought it was his
specialty okay do two
more better
how me melting with a full of fat now if
it's under ripe cheese then it's going
to be a lot harder to get running yeah
even if you cook it from Frozen it's
never going to go running because it's
not
right now the chef's gone into the
dining room that's pretty much one
member of staff for every two
customers and there are no vegetables in
the main course and they need my help to
serve them how are they ever going to
manage with more than nine
customers everything they've touched so
far this evening it's [__] overcooked
undercooked unripened deep fried cam
bear and
um I'm really worried this dining room
will be full on Sunday there could be as
many as 150 customers we don't stand a
chance and if it continues to go like it
is now there'll be more [__] cam be
inside the pot plants shocking I mean
really [__]
shocking dining room absolutely crucial
we can't do without you and you can't do
without us
and we got to establish that teamwork
and we got to come together as a team
and think together as a team and then
never forget the most important person
is the customer so it's a very
straightforward exercise Nick and I are
going to arrive in the dying room for
the first time we got a table booked for
1:30 for lunch today
ready sit me down present the menu and
sell me this restaurant here we go
Peter's been here for 15 years so he
should know what he's doing
good afternoon Mr White Horse nice to
see you Mr Ramsey long time to see you I
got a nice table for you well you can't
fo his enthusiasm still sparkly for both
of you sparkling sparkling um I have a
beer actually just Kim has been a
waiters for 5 years she's Charming but
has no real training a bear bitter
bitter okay the lamb perhaps lamb uh
yeah I'm not not too Zack's only been
here a week he knows nothing really
nothing think where's it from the L I'm
not too sure okay um oh super the day
super the day not too sure either sorry
and may have some water still sparking
yes still please still uh fresh or fresh
or oh God fresh from the pond on the
ninth green I would like you all to T we
have less than 48 hours to master the
new menu and be able to sell it to the
customers seems like got bits of muscles
in it it's not actual fish is it I'm not
sure right Seafood yeah it's it's in
seafood soup it's it's got some White
Fish there it's got cockos
C
cus this is going to be harder than the
kitchen I used to work as a waiter and
I'm sure I can show them how it's
done smoked chowder beautiful creamy sou
Gish flakes of oat smoked had finished
with a wonderful poach quy so nice beef
chowder beef chowder definitely not we
also have a special on today clam chowa
the chowa the chowa is a very nice uh PL
it's very nice T platter platter nice
short descriptive idea of the special
clam chowder very strong tasting I'm
turning [__] gray that have to be the
menu go for the menu water I'll give
I'll give the menu to you there you go
okay hold a minute let me see what we
got last time sharp tasting got a
special twist to it as we put a quail's
egg in it a quail's egg in it much
better quail's egg in it really good
even my pubes are going gray garnished
with Oaks of hadock flake sorry
garnished
with
can you cook no this whole thing is
theater and this restaurant has to
become a showcase and each and every
customer going to eat in here on Sunday
gearing up for a bloody busy day has to
remember you yes and if they remember
you and we've served good food boy are
they going to come back depending and
one last chance for Zach here we go I'm
ready this one I can feel in my bones I
can see how relaxed you are you're
looking good you're cool you're dude
bang give it to me the the smoked hadock
chal is a very nice dish um it has a
nice creamy fishy garnished with with
Flakes and a nice uh smoked hadock in
the middle he been selling like hot
cakes it would be funny if it wasn't for
Mother's Day oh [__] like two days to
prepare though so it's like oh [__]
hell you got two days to prepare one
[__] speech I got 24 hours to get
[__] R ready
Zach
Zach I'm more than halfway through my
time at more place the food's better the
waiters have improved but without any
customers is all a bit
pointless there are three days of the
year when every R should be full even
purple ones New Year's Eve Valentine's
Day and Mother's Day and Sunday is
Mother's
Day Richard and Nick have been taking
bookings trying to CLW back some money
table plan good news is what we've got
books no we've got quite a bit more than
that b hit me with it
181 [__] confirmed I should be pleased
but I'm terrified I thought we'd
struggle with 150 but 181 it's making me
feel worried slightly bit ambitious a
bit ambish Yeah but just you know what
we're trying to do and turning this
place around taking up a division yeah
getting customers in here but and what
worries me is that you know they're
still not turned on I think they been
off more than they can Che with the
amount of covers they want to do I'm as
worried as Andy but I have an idea roast
chicken just like your mother used to
make but with a Twist carved at the
table to take pressure off the kitchen
you've cut a chicken before no you've
cut a chicken before no you've cut a
chicken before many many years ago many
many years ago Rich at home of course
everyone's going to learn including the
owners one chicken each JC you thought
you were coming down here for random
golf no you're not I want you to do a
chicken ready I've brought in JC one of
my best mates he knows everything there
is to know about service and about
calving a chicken that's I mean one one
of the so classic cutting we do we first
cut off the
legs then separate the drumstick from
the
thigh next cut along the breast bone
keep the knife close to the carcass and
take off the breast I will I will leave
the skin myself yeah I think nice also
to leave the skin and the customer can
do what what he want yeah so we do one
breast one one left turn the chicken
over and remove the succulent oyster
underneath that's a nice piece of meat
that what you doing on Sunday yeah
exactly and for the next 300 Sun £450 an
hour no no we'll push the boat out this
time 475 M's got talents come on time
for everyone to practice first time for
you first time for me yeah chicken
virgin the ass walk up the ass which is
the
ass the legs off
first and then you go on to the breast
the chicken has to be carved in 3
minutes or the rest of the food will
have gone cold it doesn't really look
like a chicken one just look a bit of
bow and you cut the leg beautifully cut
the drum off you've got the thigh there
yeah look that's great don't bring it
just you're just having problems with
the breast yeah tomorrow they'll have to
carve in front of the customers and
it'll have to look better than
this nice to see you in the [__]
[__] got
some cat food here it's like the [__]
Fox is attacked the chickens are coming
on and it would be so nice to have
chickens carved at the table and getting
the waiters to take some pressure off
our [__] shoulders on Sunday with
grat and Doin WS in the bowl on the
table um fresh peas because it's just
coming to season and so that's the major
selling points for the dining room and
PE and Pie instead of being positive
about Mother's Day Mark's worrying about
old customers who are expecting the
1970s menu he's already sent out the
people that have booked have seen this
yeah as long as they know they're going
to get the beef lamb chicken Graces they
may have seen the menu but they haven't
[__] tasted it absolutely so that's
one big [__] relief for me straight
away I really want Mark to be right
behind the changes they respect of how
many we got booked we're going to be in
the [__] big time and if we can entice
25% of these customers on Sunday to
return you know I've got them yeah
you've got them they drink the simple
truth is that Nick and Richard have got
greedy and overbooked they have to learn
to care for their customers do you think
you're both now capable of running a
restaurant as you've said before and as
we've not made any bones about we're not
food experts we're not restaurant
operators our backgrounds drink um so
we've undoubtedly got lots and lots to
learn I think we need to be in here
certainly in the short to medium to we
need to keep to building our capability
if you are going to go up a division and
take it from strength to strength you
have to get firmer I have to do it every
day because there a part of me that
thinks Christ you nasty bastard and now
that you guys are physically handson I
mean really Hands-On it'd be so good to
keep control of it hold tight to those
[__] Reigns if Richard and Nick are
serious about getting stuck in we could
still get through Mother's Day I'm going
to take them at their word and give them
some real work to
do I really wish I could repaint the
building for tomorrow but at least I can
do something about the inside the you
walk in here first thing you look at
think Christ love the entrance a little
bit disorientated because you're
confused to where the rest is at the
moment the customers are in danger of
getting lost on the way into the dining
room y walk through down to the right
and then when you come into here there's
such a lovely area here and what I was
thinking see all these plants that side
let's get this over here a little bit of
screen yeah here maybe one of those
little indan screens sectioned off and
it just gives a nice smooth clear flow
through if you don't catch them they
often feel they often Mill around here
it's like it's almost a bar
disorientated come through this door
walk in first thing you see Co rail
horrible plastic coat rail so the area
outside the restro is just as important
as inside one
more
very warm it's even more intriguing now
than it is when you walk through to the
no anything wow beautiful angel
excellent where's the rest oh it's just
down here on to the right there that
natural little snake follow yeah you can
follow everything is ready for Mother's
Day just one last test to see if Richard
can carve the chicken in less than 3
minutes 3
minutes how you feeling have you started
no no yeah how I feeling yeah
overwhelmed we started at that
smart and you been
practiceing only at
home every hour of every minute of every
day one minute to
go he's done it Richard's ready to face
his
customers 2 minutes 20 well done can I
just say that we've got 50 roast
chickens for tomorrow to sell [__]
that let me think that's 100 legs that
could go into someone's lap in
it morning guys the big day has arrived
and if you're going to give the diners A
Mother's Day to Remember we better get
cracking and how many chickens are going
in six chickens down that down that oven
there got a chicken in there and then
I've got that whole tray of chickens
here as well as roast chicken Andy's
cooking a RI ey beef with all the
trimmings and irve he's in charge of the
Ora
puddings
irve you cannot make OA pudding like
this [__] hell not exactly how your
mother made them they're like bullets
maybe you have to cook them longer as
well yeah and and and hotter to start
off with just to get them Rising morning
oh you got 15 chickens it' be nice you
could do 10 of them what me personally
yeah thanks for that I'm going to start
to think about
chicken
okay here we
go y
puddings what' you reckon
50/50 fingers crossed if my Yorkshire
puddings rise the kitchen will be almost
ready okay Peter Just One Last pep talk
for the waiters I just want you to stop
crashing around move around the dining
room like a baller ARA and see that
wonderful floor out there you just treat
that like it's swung Lake gliding in and
out of all the
tables if we get this right more plays
will really take off if not we'll offend
half the mothers in
Isa oh we shouldn't be under this
pressure of [__] Mother's
Day quick look okay then just stay there
2 seconds no no no no no no no no no no
doesn't don't you blowing on them
knocking them down look at everybody
standing here W from my [__] [__] off
out of
here oh [__]
hell one more look one more look just in
case I was imagining things ready
watch go
problem there we
go
bastard right come here
please okay R look that's what I'm
trying to explain that's the York should
pudding that's a pile of [__] yes right
where's that French little [__] come
here
help and the
story okay 50 minutes to go first
table's arriving at 12:00 cour um Andy
you want to leave from the kitchen y
okay um starters smoked heck chowa is a
creamy fish souit garnished with Oak
smoke hadock main CES roast chicken half
at the table that's down to you guys
push the chicken traditional roast beef
puddings Yi
puddings CHR when you think this time
last week we went from 2 to 180 for
lunch though so I'm going to be in the
dying room right behind them give them a
little bit of support because I think
the kitchen's pretty much set with a but
dining room is still a little bit
[Music]
apprehensive bookings have been
staggered over two sittings so we'll be
working for 6 hours straight just for
the
PE after Zach's performance with the
Chowder I put him on bar
Duty Kim Nick Richard and Peter will be
working the
floor Andy's in charge of the kitchen
with Herve as he right-and
man you got 3 minutes over yeah how many
is it four how many is the chicken four
four and the executive chef well yeah
he's in charge of Crockery okay you got
three CH balls up there happy Mother's
Day hemade wpl Burger it's a thick beef
burger with a Char real bun and it
tastes brilliant it will do Nick the
world of good to meet some customers the
burgers are selling well but at the
moment not enough chicken just two or
three of you want the chicken and we
bring out to your table and cold for you
at the table how come you're not selling
the chicken it's not for one to try come
on we want to go for a
break they actually sell one chicken the
rest of the dining will start to see
sort of little bit of excitement little
bit of magic happening around the table
so they'll all start ordering which then
within an hour we'll run out which is
exactly what we need now there's a nice
Birds coming out of the
room sounds
really happy here he comes give it to
me chicken chicken for four well done
well done big boy four Ro
chicken after all my doubts it's pet who
sold the first
chicken chicken that's not you then sure
enough soon everyone wants
one it's a mutant
chicken my goodness man what's the idea
doing at
table aot chicken how do you feel about
having a chicken can on the table
different bit more
makes you feel a bit more
hungry can't find the knle think of the
drumstick what was that bit I've never
seen
[Music]
that do you want bit of each yeah that's
fine just
please relax it's only a
chicken everybody's rising to the
occasion and the first sitting is going
really
well T
to
thank you it's great to see the dining
room full and feel the buzz thank you
Lely but on the second sitting the over
booking is causing a problem there are
just too many
people there's a table of 19 and a table
of 15 and a 14 pretty much coming at the
same time and it's not very good when
you've got like 48 people all at once
because they shout in the
kitchen Nick and Richard have to learn a
cardinal rule put the customers first
make them feel really special and build
a sense of
loyalty I expect to come out for a
family meal after wait as long as this
it's not a question of fast food it's a
question now we've been an hour and a
half we've got a stter that's it not
having a lot of explanation other than
we've been really busy yeah we've kept
cheerful haven't we except for Colin
still there we are we learn and we don't
come back again that's your you ever had
a chicken CV at your table no well I've
not done this many times either Kim's
trying her best but Charming the
customers just won't work they want to
eat at least you know it's
fresh have another of wine please
remember unhappy customers destroy
reputations I mean how the [__] can you
cook for nearly 50 people at one time
[Music]
yeah the food was very good yeah the
rest of it the structure the
organization I'm sorry mate it do happen
some waiting stuffart I mean the girl's
done her best but you know she's the
only the guys in the black shirts and
everything that were the managers they
were sitting down talking to their mates
in the conservatory there and they only
left two people serving everybody else
in here I'd like to say goodbye
but still waiting to pay bill let's hope
Richard and Nick learn their lesson the
dining room's empty now but it's been
full for the first first time in a long
time and the vast majority of customers
went away
happy one chicken left
okay all well done thank you yes
happy yeah it's good working with Andy
yeah will you use my recipe for yire
puddings b a bloody French blood I
know don't wind you at the last minute
everyone's oh come on we got to the end
of the day we got to have some fisty
cuss before it goes everyone performed
in the kitchen even mark it wouldn't be
right it's an easy target at the end of
the day Mar's not an easy target yeah I
am you know you said earlier didn't you
you got a lot of material to I just love
it when you put that executive chef
before your name
hey did I and the waiters did a great
job I'm really impressed with the way
everyone pulled
together that was fantastic and you were
running around crazy today like proud
coock wow this is full this is heing
this is buzzing hey I'm running it and
happy as Larry since we started we've
never added day like we've had today in
here and you know what4 to 12 lunch time
I didn't think you were going to do it
cuz I didn't think any of you were good
enough to do it one complaint was the
fact that the food was taking too long
and the rest of the complaints were just
customers arriving again still not happy
with that Bloody
color
huh that purple monstros
let's hope we put more plays back on the
[Applause]
map when I first arrived at more place I
found a restaurant in crisis where is
everybody it felt more like a rest home
today how many boot for lunch none
nothing the food was deep fried
microwaved or out of a packet that's
[__] 70s crap at its best too many
cooks and not one of them any good are
they thank [__] I'm not hungry and I met
possibly the worst wao in the world oh
Zach I'm [__] I mean really [__]
shocking but by the end of the week
things had started to
improve now I'm back to see what's
changed oh [__] it's still purple apart
from the horrible color my biggest
problem was with the executive chef I
couldn't see the point you put
on Stone actually and you're not wearing
a chef's jacket that's even better
but at least he's staying out of the
kitchen hold of Andy missing you already
yeah
right it's the first day of Andy's new
menu morning
guys IR how are
you still happy as ever Mis [__] how
are you you well Andy how are you you're
good thanks how many new dishes you got
going on tonight chicken Mar six
starters well I've taken some of your
ideas and added some of my own ideas as
well but yeah got the hadock sh ward off
S that we done on Mother's Day Burger
how's that going yeah it's going very
well very well oh here he is want the
choice potato you got mashed potato and
chips only yeah that's it that's it yeah
don't start bringing in your Soo
potatoes and stuff like that pizza that
is all in the 15 years he's worked here
Peter's never seen so many changes Peter
still good to see you being the ultimate
pain in the ass these look nice Christ
almighty ni little um apple tarts do you
mind if I taste one yeah sure have
yourself how much they cost to make
pound yeah if that pizza Apple [__]
crispy I hope he can taste the
difference in the fresh food delicious
isn't that better than that Frozen [__]
you used to serve month ago lovely this
place just not only looks different it
smells different you think so yeah it
just smells sort of fresh fresh yeah the
front's still
purple R wasn't bu a day was it true
that's
true are the staff causing any
problems he's he seems to be working out
right he's a bit negative but once you
show him how to do something and see get
him on your way of thinking then uh yeah
he can see the improvements Have You
Bullet Mark yet yeah today oh
good how's Zach doing smoke had at CH
look at him over there give it to me
sell it to me I remember it correctly
it's a it's a creamy fish shot garnished
with a flakes of Oak hadock and a nice
qu leg in the middle my God he can do it
let's hope Andy doesn't change the menu
too soon thanks Zach okay new menu and
new start and is exactly what this place
needs uh more place Burger we have um
seed salmon and it's on a champ MH he
cooked for 181 guests on Mother's Day
and everyone went away happy apart from
a table of 19 I hope Richard and Nick
have learned from that it's all twos
threes fours sixes there's no 19s or
anything like that it's all nice good
easy stuff uh 27 whether there's 20
customers or 200 the service got to
match the food let's keep it nice for
tonight one last thing it really breaks
my heart when uh I've put sauce and
everything on the plate and the waiters
come along and they throw all the plates
up their arms if the sauce is nice and
thick but I miss the sa not a bur in no
thick sauces there's no parley there are
no tomatoes thicken them with a bit ofn
not a [__] Burnie in no two chicken
marylands one French fries one veg thank
you we got a new um head chef who
started about 4 weeks ago hopefully
you'll stay it's good to see Nick
engaging with customers I try my
best Andy what you recommend I have for
dinner I quite like the lamb I like the
sign of the um salmon as well special
yeah have we sold any yet yeah we sold
uh sold
three we
are the waiters look like they're
enjoying their jobs and getting excited
about the new food
service nice Buzz tonight yeah yeah
really nice Buzz presentation looks nice
y it's simple
unfussy I've never been a big fan of
fried Leakes but that's a garnish are
you both happy so far with the sort of
not American restaurant but the theme
side to the food happy yes um I'd love
to see farmal bums on seats I think the
the biggest thing for me has been we've
actually got someone in the kitchen that
cares as much as we do about the
business the staff said on Sunday it was
probably the first time they' ever taken
food out that they knew wasn't coming
back starters are a knockout thanks K
they've got a real asset in
handy we never ever pretended to be
restaurant we're not you two guys that
have got the potential to go all the way
providing you remove yourself from the
best mate scenario with a staff and
start tiing the screws a little bit you
guys are smart him smart then I get Fri
tuck walking in with a [__] scruffy
t-shirt on and a pair of jeans look at
him now at that
table just you know even if you just
send them upstairs and say look [__] off
out of here go and get a shirt on
because you do look like a sack of [__]
I'm totally in agreement with you this
is about discipline Richard and it's
very hard to implement discipline when
you're so close to these guys yeah the
rest is not full every night but
turnover is already up 20% super
100 guests going through a day six days
a week turning you know 18 20 grand a
week
alone I swear to God you guys have got a
[__] gold mine on your hands can I
just show you one more thing I know
don't no no I want to show you how to
play [__]
golf oh just the one more
thing would you like me to put some clim
film on the pond so when it splashes in
there we don't hear it thank you it's
great to see the dying room busy and the
ran making money at last if Nick and
Richard can attract as many custom they
get on the golf course their more plays
can be a big success I didn't know they
were going to be so bright like that so
you can actually see them whisk through
the air do they
float we'll
see oh I've got one left [__] hell
but that was a [__] [__] shot you
know that well I've played a lot worse
and you know what it's like me inviting
you to my restaurant and [__] your
omelette that's what it's like Pringle
pants Pringle socks Pringle jumper GE
Pringle glove all the gear here no idea
and no [__]
bollocks oh look at that
beautiful